hey guys pete here
let's talk about better call saul season
six episode seven
we lost one there's a big character
ending to talk about and so much more
it was a really fantastic episode from
writer director thomas schnauz and i've
invited some of my friends here to
discuss everything that happened
lalo's return
d-day in all its glory and the end of
howard's story
they had been setting things up over the
past few episodes and we'd all been
wondering what the payoff would be and
we definitely got one
i'm gonna have my two guests introduce
themselves and tell us what their
general impressions of the episode were
and then i'll respond to that before we
go through everything that happened in
plan and execution
i really didn't think there would be an
actual execution
but there were so many great little
details that tie things together there
was just uh you know it was there were
so many good shots the way that things
were set up and
it was a real roller coaster of you know
emotions
a nice balance of everything all in one
and um we are gonna be joined by
kiwi he's he's on his way he's gonna be
a little bit late so why don't you tell
me what you thought about the episode
first gill
sure to the shock of everyone here i'm
sure i'll say that i loved the episode
uh and of course i'm being sarcastic
because i think that's pretty universal
even the people who haven't been happy
with the pace of the season so far i
think tonight's episode or last night's
episode moved at a pretty uh brisk pace
to everyone's liking but exactly what
you said it was an emotional roller
coaster it was a highlights reel of all
the best things better call saul does
and all of it cranked up to 11. the
first few minutes of the episode were
hilarious
often better call saul is funny but i
was laughing constantly for you know
five to ten minutes at the start of the
episode just watching the casimiro body
double watching jimmy and kim scramble
then it quickly segues into
gut wrenching nervous territory every
time the camera cuts to howard's eyes
and i'm checking to see if they're
dilated yet every time he kind of
fixes his collar a little bit you start
to get nervous
of course it becomes shocking later it
becomes tragic so just a roller coaster
ride of an episode the other thing it
does so well that better call saul often
does well
is the imagery i mentioned the dilated
pupils there's the cockroach that's the
thing which makes lalo think of saul
which is just amazing and then of course
the candle flicker which will go down in
history as one of the most memorable
ominous little images we've ever seen on
television and i said i said at the
beginning of my of my video i don't
think i'll i'll ever look at one of
those camera flickers the same way again
if i'm in a room and i see a candle
flicker i'm hitting the deck immediately
lala's here
the one thing i'd add just
one more reason why i love this episode
so much is that it didn't happen in the
second to last or third to last episode
of the series one thing that always
frustrates me when you have a lot of
character building and a lot of setup
you don't get to the climax until right
at the end of the series and then you
don't get to live with the fallout and
really explore it but here we have six
episodes left so we get to watch jimmy
and kim live with what happened see what
that does to them
and i'm excited to see that at the same
time the show is definitely starting to
test the limits of how much it can make
me hate characters and still care about
what happens to them because jimmy and
kim are definitely starting to straddle
the line for me
or possibly they have floored it past
that line but i still very much care and
want to see what happens with them so
stellar episode love the fact that we
have a few more to explore what happens
after it
and
can't wait and am scared to see what
comes next
yeah and i you know that that was one of
the things that um
it really shows how good they are at
developing characters you know they they
they brought howard to this point where
you know you really do
like it doesn't matter what you think
about him or anything else you really do
have to feel for him
and at the same time they're making it
very hard to feel for for
jimmy and kim and i mean this is
something we understand from this
universe you know that that people are
you know sometimes that their their bad
side comes out and you see them you know
in their in their anti-hero glory kind
of thing you know what i mean but like
it's we're still at the point where i i
want something better to happen for
these two
and
and they kind of they kind of they kind
of threaded this or you know they kind
of made this like this really
smart move to
have them do something have it work out
but then
make the you know the unforeseen
consequence be something that they could
have never planned for because that
still gives them a chance that they
might be able to rethink
you know what they were actually doing i
kind of doubt it you know what i mean
like i don't think that's really the
direction they're going but it is a
possibility so
yeah i thought i was thinking today
how can jimmy and kim redeem themselves
would there be a path toward redemption
and if howard were alive
in the ideal world it would be them
confessing to what happened publicly
tarnishing their reputation which jimmy
has essentially already done in order to
reconstruct howard's reputation
obviously it's too late for that
and then i started to think who's
responsible for this last night in the
live chat over on my channel there was a
lot of discussion over who's to blame
here jimmy kim and it's easy to forget
that lalo is the one who made the
decision to pull the trigger who's
responsible for howard's death i mean
the guy who killed him has to bear some
of the responsibility but it is funny
how we almost think of lalo or i guess
speaking for myself i found myself
almost thinking of him as an evil force
like it's wrong to expect he would have
done anything else
so you have to put the blame on jimmy
and kim because they're the ones who
have invited trouble into their lives
versus lalo you just couldn't expect
anything else but those are some of the
thoughts it's a complex situation that's
why we love the show so much and those
are some of the complicated feelings
i've been wrestling with today
yeah absolutely i mean it's it's not
something i mean i'm not happy that
there's a break necessarily but you know
it's it's
there's a lot of good things to think
about in that time and it and it will
kind of add to the experience of of
picking back up with it later to see you
know where the where it goes from here
so uh chase you made it
why don't you uh give us your
introduction tell the tell the viewers
who you are and
let me know what you think your general
impressions of the episode
yeah sure so uh hey guys kiwi here um
running a little bit late but i'm glad i
could make it um
honestly my first impressions is just
com complete silence just could just
jaw on the floor i can't believe this
happened even with you know certain
subtle foreshadowings such as lalo
looking at the cockroach and all of that
i honestly didn't see this coming um
for over a year now i guess we were all
sort of predicting that
law or that howard was gonna die somehow
we thought it was gonna be a suicide or
something like that maybe he gets caught
up in some business with the cartel
while trying to track jimmy and kim down
with the pi but uh yeah i did not expect
it to go down this way i think this is
one of the most tragic deaths of the
entire show or the entire universe in
general and um i guess in a way i kind
of am glad uh if howard had to die that
it wasn't a suicide because it didn't
just kind of copy chuck's death but also
i i i love the the parallel of the first
time that lalo went to kim's apartment
he left without any blood on his hands
and this is clearly just
i mean it's a parallel but it's going
down just a completely different road
and i'm really nervous for uh for kim's
i mean i don't even i feel like i kind
of hate jimmy and kim now but i still am
scared for uh for kim i mean we know
jimmy has some plot armor because he's
in breaking bad in gene but i'm really
scared that kim might not come out of
this one alive and it might be a little
bit too much to kill two characters so
soon but you know lalo killing howard
really shows that he means business and
i think there is kind of a possibility
that
uh lalo might not leave that apartment
building with kim alive
hmm
interesting um i didn't i didn't
i didn't have any immediate concern for
her life but uh we'll we'll get into
this later because i mean
as as they
as they thin the herd as they get rid of
some of these characters who we don't
know the endings for
it starts to feel more like they're all
going to die
you know i mean it just seems like it's
getting more inevitable because the ways
out
each time the ways out seem a little
less
doable you know what i mean like
you know
the idea of kim being in prison you know
that always seemed like something that
might be might make sense but i mean if
she she can't go to prison for howard's
murder or else like that doesn't that
kind of takes her off the board
indefinitely so you know what i mean
like things get
it really kind of changed the trajectory
but without like saying hey this is
where we're going you know just to sort
of announce the fact that
things are going to take a turn here and
that's a good place to leave a
mid-season finale considering that they
didn't plan it ahead of time
so yeah i agree with uh you know
everything that that you guys were
saying there um
you know the roller coaster of it all
i mean that you know the
the the there was there was the moment
like you know obviously when you're
watching
the d-day play out you feel for howard
because it's uh you know you realize
that his career is coming to an end that
it's coming off you know what i mean
or not coming to an end but you know
he's gonna take this real hit and
still it's so funny some of the stuff
that happens like whenever i first saw
the picture of the um
the uh you know the uh
the camera guy or the microphone guy
with his frisbee
i mean i will never be able to look at
that photo and not laugh at the top of
my lungs you know i mean like it was
audible i was just completely laugh out
loud
and it's like you know it's a really
weird combination of things to be
feeling at the same time because they're
destroying someone's career
and it's someone that we've been trained
to like a lot more in the last couple of
episodes or last couple seasons
and at the same time it's hilarious and
there was the turn there was the
there was the um
what's her name aaron on the on the uh
conference call like when she's talking
to people and there was all of that that
was hilarious and um
the uh
what's her name irene uh irene yeah her
when she turns and says that these
always go that way i mean these were
some of the most comedic moments of the
entire season you know and it's all and
it's all there together
and and i was talking to gil about this
before but you know it they kind of
fooled with the timeline
in a way that it wasn't it didn't really
seem possible that howard and lalo could
meet up at the end of this episode
but at the same time it didn't feel like
some kind of dirty trick or sleight of
hand it just you know it made sense in
the moment and
that actually because i mean that was a
con you know that was a pretty popular
theory that you know kind of went to the
background this over these last few
episodes because you just didn't think
lolo was going to be there at that time
and so you know that really worked to to
make that
you know even though it felt like it was
going to happen for sure
you still it's still you still were in
the moment or still i was still in the
process of like trying to wrap my head
around it like oh my god howard's gonna
die you know it's gonna happen right
here
so it was a you know it was a fantastic
um
you know there was just everything was
working um
we'll get into each thing you know
individually here in a second
but we do have some uh super chats here
so why don't we knock those out really
quick and then we'll um
we'll transition into the recap as it
were
so just let me try to scroll back here
gil did you um
how much did you think it was possible
at the beginning of the episode that
howard might die by the end uh i i think
i'm on tape yesterday i'm on record
saying howard's not going to die tonight
it just
it it just it felt like too much
and i thought about it when you were
just saying that lawl is showing up it
didn't feel like a cheat and i think
part of the reason it didn't feel like
they were cheating by having him
basically skip the flight home and
saying the timeline wasn't what we
thought part of the reason that felt
earned is because they already trained
us this season to realize we're skipping
large portions of lalo's journey every
time we see him he's somewhere else
we saw him early in the season next time
we find him he's in germany next time we
find him
he's already found casper so
they kind of tricked me the other way by
moving things so slowly the last three
episodes where they trained me to expect
lalo to be able to jump from one place
to another the same time they trained me
to expect a slower paced season so i
thought
no way going into this episode are we
getting a death even though the title
was playing an execution i thought
they're trying to trick us it's not
going to happen
and
i think that speaks a little bit to the
whole setup versus payoff part of that
was in the setup
yeah i'm on tape saying that i didn't
think there was going to be a little
literal execution either because how
could there have been you know i mean it
just really it was it was really
it was always a possibility but it
wasn't front and center
um
chase do you want to add anything did
you think at the beginning of the
episode we might see howard
go out
i mean i don't know i definitely thought
it was more metaphorical than literal it
was always kind of a possibility but as
i said it was definitely a surprise and
just kind of to touch on what you said
about how comedic the first few parts of
this episode are like
it it really just almost seemed like a
comedy like i was i was really cheerful
and enjoying this episode during the
beginning with the camera crew and all
that and then just the further the
episode goes on the darker and darker
and darker it gets and i just find it
really amazing that this episode touches
both the comedic moments of the show and
also the dramatic moments of the show
just so amazingly but yeah no i i did
not think there'd be a literal execution
but hey i guess those titles are really
do mean what they say
yeah i agree like one of the things that
i noticed right in the in the opening
was the way that they were the way that
they were contrasting the two different
paces you know you had lalo on his side
with his slow and deliberate
going to take his shower doing all this
stuff and then as soon as we go with uh
kim and jimmy they're just it's just
completely kinetic you know things are
just one after the other boom boom boom
it's a race against the clock
and you know it when you look back on
that then you see how those two things
came together that was that was a really
great thing and just like you said you
know the way that they balanced um
you know fun with with sirius and and
laughing to uh shock you know what i
mean it was it was it was a real a real
mixture of
all the things that you'd like to see in
one hour of television so ahura
thank you for the 20
he asked what was lalo thinking when
when howard was telling off kim and
jimmy
i'm going to assume that lala was in the
room the entire time
my impression was that he wasn't in
there for the bulk of that he um
you know they had the flicker the the
candle flicker that that showed when he
opened the door because i guess it was
still unlocked after
you know they let howard in earlier um
did either one of you did either one of
you think that he might have overheard
anything important there
that wasn't my impression
i kind of felt that he didn't care who
this guy was he was just a third party
uh he can't leave any witnesses to his
being alive or to whatever's about to
happen next so
the mental calculation was this guy
needs to go maybe he listened just
enough to assess the situation
and kind of ding okay this guy is
irrelevant he needs to be gotten rid of
uh yeah no i i don't really think that
he heard all too much more than you know
before it was actually revealed that
lala was there
um i
i'm just gonna say something and i'm
drawing a blank um
i'm i'm just really trying to think here
because i don't really think that he
he knew too much more than honestly
honestly come back to me in a second i
was about to say something and i
completely forgot
okay aaron thank you for the five
dollars give me what we know now
can you revisit the season teaser of
saul's luxurious mansion yeah i i i
don't think we can do that right at this
moment but um
that's something we can keep in mind for
later and that is something that i'm
gonna revisit in between
seasons and uh probably in a video so be
on the lookout for that
mg thank you for the ten dollars how did
the croatian know address of
laundromat to tell lalo
thought werner and the boys were
blindfolded etc to keep location secret
while working now this is something that
i looked into a couple of weeks ago and
uh or maybe it was last week but they
they definitely put them in a a truck
that has the markings of the the of the
laundry place and they only really
hooded them and blindfolded them when
they first came from from the airport so
they they kept it secret as far as where
it actually was but
i don't think that they were as careful
as we might have as it might have felt
when we were watching that originally
like there were definitely some details
that could have came through that he
could have told lalo and then we can
imagine lala being smart and resourceful
could uh put the things together from
there
uh so i actually do remember what i was
just gonna say a moment ago sorry about
the brain fart but uh
so just in regards to i guess howard
still having an opportunity to leave
before lalo showed up it just got me
thinking in regards to how long was lalo
standing there before he sort of entered
the room
i do think that's a good point that you
made with the candle flickering implying
that the door was opening and that's
when lalo actually joined the scene as a
whole but i mean i i did tweet out
saying oh howard just should have left
when he had a chance and people are
telling me oh he was gonna be dead
regardless but there there was a solid
minute or two before i think lalo
actually showed up where howard totally
could have left because kim and jimmy
were telling howard like okay you need
to stop this you need to leave you need
to get out of here and they were saying
that for a solid minute or so before
lalo actually showed up so in a sense i
i guess two-part answer here i think
that it was possible if howard would've
just left when they told him to that he
would still be alive
and because of that i don't actually
think that lalo was just lurking around
the corner listening to the whole
conversation until uh until it was
obvious that he was there
yeah those are good points um
mg had another uh five dollars thank you
for that
uh this was something that i was
thinking about just a minute ago
whenever i was uh getting the the the um
slides ready for this
and he asked when jimmy said how upon la
la la's return
do you think that
had a double meaning was he trying to
trying to but unable to warn howard to
leave i thought the same thing i didn't
pick up on that the first watch but
obviously he's saying how like how are
you alive
but i think that they are playing with
the idea that he was he was so scared
that he was trying to continue what they
were doing with howard saying like
howard you got to go and that's all he
got out was was how it sort of morphed
into that
either of you guys want to chime in on
that
is that something you noticed
uh it's not something i noticed but one
thing i kept having to remind myself is
that jimmy did not know that lalo is
alive i had to remind myself because we
knew and kim knew
and when you remember that you realized
that to him
somebody he thought was dead just
strolled into his apartment so of course
the first question you'd ask is how and
whether or not he was thinking howard
when he said it the sentiment that would
lead him to say howard was definitely
there just a mix of this guy is now in
the crosshairs and he shouldn't be and
how are you alive
why are you here
well just in regards to that just the
whole idea of jimmy not knowing but kim
knowing is i don't know if she thought
it would be okay just because she
thought that mike's men were looking
after him but i always did wonder like
how mad is jimmy gonna be if if lalo
just pops around a corner and he i
always thought that lala was going to
confront either kim by herself or jimmy
by himself i didn't think that they
would confront them both together just
the way that they did and in such a
moment where mike's men aren't watching
over them it's just such a
such such a horrible situation to put
yourself in but if they do survive this
situation i really think that uh jimmy
and kim are gonna have a serious talk
about why the heck didn't you tell me
lala was still alive
yeah it's interesting because you wonder
if i mean it seems like jimmy's in a
spot where he can justify almost
anything that kim does and and so
that'll be that'll be interesting to see
if that is a thing because he's he's
obviously terrified on a level that
we've never seen uh jimmy saul or gene
experience
before
sergeant paul thank you for the 4.99 he
asks if
or they ask is anyone else tired of the
fact mike can do everything he can be a
civil engineer a sniper a bricklayer
security guy and this week on
mib uh man in black am i like he was
chasing aliens
hmm
i don't really get i don't i don't
really get tired of it how about you go
no i mean to me they all feel like
skills that
relate to one another
not that that somebody has to be both a
sniper and an engineer but i feel like
somebody that's interested in one of
those things
it's not a
giant leap for me to believe they would
also be interested in these other things
so yeah i buy it maybe if he can explain
what he means by mib i would say
what no that one doesn't fit i don't buy
it
yeah
i'm kind of lost on that too
okay so
jay wilkes thank you for the five
dollars lalo and kim can take the money
elope buy the tax place from the
kettleman's and gift saw the salt statue
of liberty as consolation
and live happily ever after
that is a creative idea i don't know
that it's gonna happen but um chase you
want to add anything to that idea there
i just find it so funny how going into
season six with the trailers and how we
saw
excuse me how we saw the statue of
liberty teased at us i thought that was
gonna be a major part of the season like
finding out how i mean i guess we did
see saul get his office and stuff like
that but we still haven't seen him get
his breaking bad car and we still
haven't seen that statue of liberty blow
up and after everything that's happened
in season six honestly that statue of
liberty blow up is just in the back of
my head like i assume there'll be a
small moment where they give it to them
i mean i feel like kim kind of has the
kettleman's under her thumb so you know
assuming she survives the confrontation
with lalo she could probably just get
them to give it to jimmy and honestly do
whatever she wants
yeah
colin wallace thank you for the five
dollars how will lalo factor into hiding
slash disposing of howard's body will it
end up being a stage suicide situation
this is a good question um i don't
really know he was so casual about it he
didn't really seem to be concerned one
way or the other
at the same time he he couldn't have
showed up there you know he
it wasn't on his mind that he was going
to murder a third person when he walked
in the door so
what do you think uh gil what do you
think he's going to do they will they
set it up or will they just make him
disappear
uh well i think
i think they'll want to make him
disappear i guess i keep going back and
forth on this because it feels like you
could stage it as a suicide there are
enough outside observers who believe
they saw howard just tumbling toward
rock bottom so you think they might buy
it uh in terms of how lala would factor
in he has an incentive he doesn't want
to leave a trail of dead bodies behind
him what i could see is he knows that
jimmy and kim also have an incentive to
get rid of that body because they don't
want to get roped into a murder
situation
so
he's dealt with this many times before
so i could see him in a somewhat
humorous manner casually giving them
some advice on how to get rid of a body
because he's done it so many times
before
but yeah stage suicide feels right to me
but but we'll see
do you have any thoughts on that chase
uh yeah definitely a few i mean i don't
really think that lalo is gonna be too
worried about uh leaving bodies in his
wake so to speak i mean he did just you
know kind of burn fred i travel wire to
a crisp and just leave him there if
anything i feel like lalo is just gonna
let them deal with it and again assuming
they both survive the situation they're
probably gonna have to call up mike and
maybe get him to come help with the the
body cleanup i don't know if they're
gonna be able to stage it as a suicide
i'm not sure if the the hole through
howard's head like as far as forensics
go if that'll confirm that it is or
isn't a suicide along with cleaning up
any dna left in the apartment but the
first time that we ever did see mike in
breaking bad was him helping clean up
jane's death for jesse so i think that
could be a good call back getting mike
to come and help with this situation
yeah an introverted illusion asked
something similar for thank you for the
499. do you think howard dying in kim
and jimmy's apartment has something to
do with jimmy getting a new house i know
it's a reach
i think it would be hard for them to
just hang out in that apartment that
they've been in for so long knowing that
howard died right there i mean
they had mixed feelings about the guy
but he was someone that was part of
their life and and their you know they
have responsibility in what happened to
him so
i don't know i think that that's a uh
it definitely could be a factor
slant mott
i guess i don't know that's um that's
those are two words that are back to
back hard for me to pronounce thank you
for the
ca the canadian 699
do you think lala will clean up or leave
kim and jimmy with the body well chase
just touched on this and i think that
you know there's a good possibility that
he'll make it their responsibility he's
already on the run he's already got you
know a ton of other stuff on his mind
and i don't think that
he's particularly concerned about the
wake of whatever he does there
but you know jimmy and kim are useful
for him so he doesn't want them to
really go to prison either and you know
they could they could definitely give up
some information so i think he'd
probably help them
but they're gonna have to be complicit
in it
crazy protractor beard thank you for the
canadian 279 is this the first time lalo
has killed on screen
um
well he did kill fred off screen he did
kill mateo off screen
either one of you have a quick answer to
this of whether we've seen him kill
someone before
i don't i don't think we have because
the only other example i can think of is
when he was going to get on the truck to
go across the border and that one was
also off screen you only heard it
so i don't know chase if you remember
anything else
i mean the only time that i can think of
that we actually have seen lalo kill
someone on screen is when he killed all
of those hitmen in the season five
finale but besides that just killing
like an individual usually it always is
off screen
yeah but that is the answer he he
definitely
mortally wounded if not killed people in
that in that shootout at his house
didn't he
okay chris cristiano amaral thank you
for the five euro do you guys think
howard's wife is gonna revenge him
right is that the way is that revenge
and go after kim and jimmy i do not i
think that there is a part i think they
they sort of set that up in a way that
we know that um
she kind of doesn't she's kind of over
him like in in
they they've obviously been going
through something he mentions in this
episode it's
been that he's been in the guest house
for uh the better part of a year so i
kind of feel like
in a strange way
that's
you know i don't see
i don't think there's relief i mean
nobody's relieved when they find out
someone that they were in a relationship
dies but
i don't see her it seems like there's
enough
other stuff going on that this isn't
something that she would act she we
don't know anything about her to know
that she would go after anyone
but i mean you know it doesn't seem like
the situation where she'll be a factor
as far as like you know trying to uh
make trouble for our or you know jimmy
and kim either of you guys want to weigh
in on that
just that i agree with you and i think
however
howard's death is handled i don't think
it'll be public knowledge that jimmy and
kim were involved nor do i think it'll
be public knowledge that they were
involved in everything that went down at
the sandpiper meeting so i don't think
even if she was out for revenge i don't
see a scenario where she would know that
jimmy and kim
would be the target of that revenge even
though she knows that jimmy was messing
with them in the past with the bowling
balls i think she has a healthy
skepticism about i don't know if i'd say
healthy but she has a skepticism of
howard where i don't even know she'd
fully believe that that was all jimmy's
doing or if there was some paranoia and
some sort of a grudge between them so i
think
she's gonna leave well enough alone and
do her best to move on with her life
yeah i think she's gonna leave well
enough alone too i mean it also just
depends how well uh the howard cover-up
ends up going down
uh if she was more passionate towards
howard then maybe she would kind of you
know stick her nose in somewhere it
doesn't belong maybe get herself in some
trouble but considering how much in
disarray their marriage is i i feel like
she's just gonna kind of accept her
losses and try and move on
yeah o-s-r-s elgin thank you for the
five dollars it's a it's a declaration
not a question kim's fault this happened
she withheld that lala was alive and
saul was gonna abort mission until kim
insisted on moving forward
blame equals kim so that is a
declaration that's that's a point of
view you can have if you uh if that's
the way you feel
i do want to talk about a little bit
about aborting the mission and all those
things later when we talk about uh the
actual episode so we'll come back to
that i'll give you guys both the chance
to talk about that then
rod kiefer thank you for the 4.99 i'd
forgotten that the boys had gone out
with mike and berner for r r maybe
that's how they knew where they were
rip howard hamlin yeah i think it's you
know
i i think it really comes down to
it just takes a little bit of
information for
someone as as as resourceful as we've
seen lalo be
to find out where this place is but that
is a good point they were out and about
they did see a bunch of of albuquerque
so there's there's definitely it
definitely makes sense it doesn't feel
like something that that's unexplained
to me
eric alvarado thank you for the 1999
when mike said tyrus and his crew were
at the laundromat
i knew lalo wasn't going there anymore
i'm not 100 sure if that is
is what's happening um
i mean i don't think we're supposed to
know a hundred percent sure what what
lala is going to do next um what i took
away from that scene when i watched it
the second time was that
part of them you know seeing the actual
crew move around in real time as he's
doing things
i think he realized that they were
really prepared for him to show up and
that maybe he didn't understand that
before
so i think it's all a setup as far as
you know he's gonna have to figure out
his plan
and you know as he goes i don't think i
think i think whatever he was originally
going to do he he's not going to do any
more and i think you're right whenever
um i i don't know if it i i guess you're
saying that it hit you whenever
mike said that
um i i thought it for me it kind of came
to me whenever they we saw the people
moving around how how people were
redeploying in in relation to what was
happening right he made the phone call
and basically told hector's plan and he
realized while they're listening in
so
he
hung up called again
and told he said that gus is getting a
surprise so at that point we know he
called an audible i don't think he knew
his next step yet but it wasn't the
laundromat and then he saw the cockroach
and that's when it hit him he came up
with something involving saul
yeah i totally agree
yeah i that definitely was his original
plan but then after realizing that the
phones were tapped and gus was probably
on to him he decided to not do that
anymore but he decided to you know give
gus a red herring and pretend that he
still was
yep and jay wilkes thank you for the
five dollars wonder if they did any
re-whites
do wonder if they did any rewrites and
filming after 607 became a break episode
also curious if producers underestimated
lalo's popularity with bcs fans
as far as i know they didn't do any
rewrites um
i listened to a little bit of the
insider podcast before we did this and
tomaszena said it just sort of worked
out that way it didn't sound like they
made any any last-second adjustments
and i think they i think that
vince has said that they you know
he he was against the idea of creating a
character
lalo and he was won over right away
whenever they you know they they had
tony dalton come in so i think they
probably understand that that we feel
the same way about the character too i
mean they they they may have
underestimated the idea but i think once
they found their lala you know with tony
dalton that they they knew that they had
something good going on
james miola thank you for the five
dollars well the five original main bcs
characters kim lalo nacho chuck and
howard all be dead when breaking bad
comes around could see lalo dead kim
hiding in
nebraska
yeah that's i'm guessing
um yeah that would make sense i mean
i don't know i like i said at the
beginning i think that it feels more
possible than ever that they're all
gonna die
let's do a quick round table here chase
what about you
could they all die
um honestly yeah i think so but the
thing that surprises me the most is that
i kind of thought that lalo was going to
die first out of all of them and he
might be the one that survives the
longest out of all of them because i'm
honestly kind of 50 50 on if kim will
die in the next episode with this whole
confrontation obviously you know nacho
chuck and howard have all had their fate
set in stone so yeah i honestly think
that i mean if kim's going to die at all
i think that lalo might out survive her
before he perishes as well
go ahead gail yeah i think lalo it feels
to me like a foregone conclusion he's
going to die and at this point it's just
a matter of how much collateral damage
will he take with him we've already seen
howard who else possibly kim
i like kim being alive just because the
idea of a gene reunion is so
juicy to me i really want to see that
but her her future is such an open book
i try to speculate on it sometimes but i
love not knowing so we'll see
and uh trustee thank you for the 50 that
is very generous
late to the party again because these
chats always happen during nba finals
nothing to say except thank you to all
three of you your content and analysis
is great i'll have to restart this later
so thanks a lot for that it's really
appreciated
momon143 thank you for the five dollars
barfling that was a underrated uh
underrated moment in the episode i think
that's chock full of so many of them
um thank you for that
i'm scrolling here we go
adam kasana thank you for the uh
canadian five dollars how do you think
the series will end
transition into breaking bad i'm still
surprised we didn't get any gene takavic
in the intro of this season
well i think that there will be some
crossover and i think that we will get a
lot of gene in the end
do you have anything to add to that gill
this is something we've addressed a
couple of times already yeah only thing
is that i i feel like i hope we get one
or two episodes of gene for the same
reasons i said earlier where i love when
the big thing happens
and then we spend some time afterward
exploring the impact and the fallout so
i don't want to get a 10 minute gene
epilogue i want to really spend time
with him and see how jimmy looks back on
his life reckons with himself and uh do
we get a happy ending a bittersweet one
i can't wait to find out
yep
chase
i i definitely do want to see at least
one full gene episode i hope that maybe
we get two uh considering that they
never planned on this season being split
halfway i don't think that we'll see
gene in the next episode although i
really wish that we could get some sort
of teaser with him at some point besides
like the final episode of the show but i
trust the writers and as long as we get
at least one full gene episode i'm gonna
be really happy and i i am even though i
don't know if kim will survive i i do
still really want that gene kim reunion
as well so you know fingers crossed
yeah penguin coconuts thank you for the
five dollars i'm confused about the
timeline judge in liquor store kim
driving back emergency photo shoot all
happened before 7 a.m on the same day
yeah uh they they touched on all of
these things during the episode i
noticed when i was going back and doing
my notes to try to make it all seem to
seem you know normal
he said he came in at 10 a.m
and he went to the liquor store and so
i'm not really sure what the what the
actual thing is but i mean the meeting
is happening in the in the after lunch
it seems like to me um
and i would have to i mean i would have
to go back to either one of you off the
top of your head have like a solid
timeline of everything that happened on
d-day
nope i'll make i do love to make
spreadsheets to figure out the
complicated timelines of things that's
what i did for dark so maybe i'll bring
those skills back for this episode at
some point
yeah i don't know
all that i know is that yeah uh howard
accused him of being in the park at what
seven in the morning and then he says he
wasn't gonna he wasn't there until 10.
so uh yeah definitely definitely the
timeline does not match up of course we
know it was a mediator body double so
that's why but yeah
yeah so mg thank you for the two dollars
again by the way tried to tried turning
soda can trick did not work
this is one of the things i heard on the
insider podcast that uh thomas schnauz's
father taught him this and and it did
work according to him but i have not
tested it myself have you have either of
you guys tested this
not yet but i plan to
yeah i'm not a big soda drinker really
anything in can so
i had i didn't have anything on hand to
check it
out learning some fun facts about each
other peat peppers does not drink out of
cans i didn't know that i'm not
anti-cans i just don't usually keep them
around the house you know what i mean
right right
luke duke thank you for the canadian
five dollars do you feel saul will dress
in the howard costume to move the jaguar
from the parking lot with a body in the
trunk
i did not think about that but i do love
the idea now that i have um
he's got all that right there
he could actually be howard for a couple
of days and he's got a filming crew that
could uh
could fabricate evidence to make it look
like he's still alive
rakes muhammad thank you for the 9.99
the way i look at it what makes lalo
such a neat unique threat to gus is that
he's basically an extension of hector
if he wasn't in a wheelchair
your thoughts i i think you know for me
and we can just do a quick round table
on this for me what makes lalo stack up
well against
uh gus is that he's he's way more
he's way more well-rounded than the
other salamancas the other silent
monkeys are just like
violence you know i mean
smash something kill something
he can actually you know match gus on on
you know
the strategic level on being able to
think things through and anticipate you
know different things so yeah we can
just do a quick what do you think gus
or gil sorry
it's all good
uh like i said i love being confused for
gus he's such an intelligent and uh
strategic person and i think that is
like you highlighted the thing that
makes lalo such a threat is the fact
that i think he's smarter than hector uh
i think he's a more formidable foe the
fact that he's so
has so much physical ability i think is
more of a fun character trait that
definitely helps him out here and there
but the main thing is how cunning he is
i think that's his biggest strongest
trait
yeah that's the thing i do think that he
is a little bit more calculated than any
other salamanca we've ever seen normally
they just kind of brute force their way
through things but the thing about lalo
is that he is so charismatic but
devilishly so and it's the first time
we've ever seen a salamanca like that so
you know he knows how to be comic
collected when he needs to he knows how
to be charming when he needs to and uh
clearly from the end of this last
episode he knows how to be deadly when
he needs to as well which is just what
makes him so dangerous
absolutely jb painting thank you for the
a five dollars i don't know where the a
is referring to i'd love to see the
timeline converge with breaking bad with
a saw pov and a scene suddenly being bra
being bagged and kidnapped leading to
hearing it was the ignacio line
um
yeah i i i'm not as
a lot of people would like to see some
of those uh you know
those scenes re rethought or um
you know from a different perspective
i'm not as big of a i'm not as excited
about that i i'd like to see a lot of
new stuff that we would that we've never
seen before and then into my head i can
connect it to all those things that i
already like from the show
but um
it's i get where you're coming from it's
a you know there's a lot of potential in
that breaking bad timeline
shane connell thank you for the ten
dollars the fake pi just probably lied
he took the yeah so
this is something i wasn't sure about
where that 7 a.m came from so thanks for
clearing that up shane the pi definitely
lied he took it right before he um
walked in the room
so that's a thank you for that
torchington 199. i wonder if how they'll
reintroduce
something we've talked about several
times uh we're not really sure
if they will it was 10 months we haven't
really passed any time yet so
i feel like it's there in the background
he's he's there if they need him but
we can also put that stuff together off
screen to understand how that happened
uh but depending on what happens with
lalo how do you guys think lolu will die
thank you samwise for the five dollars
part of me is hoping he kills kim
and in the gene timeline we see gene
killing lalo as revenge
i don't expect him to make it to that
part because i think it would screw up
all the stuff that happens in breaking
bad and
just they would they would have to
really explain how
gus goes from this
you know
complete mess of a basket case he is
that lala's out there to not thinking
that he's
out there anymore but um
that would be dramatic if gene kills him
in the you know if he
if he slays his demon or
whatever you might you know whatever
you would say with that do either you
guys want to add something to this
i mean i mean it kind of has been sort
of a popular theory floating around ever
since the beginning of season five that
maybe lalo survives to the gene timeline
maybe this jeff the cab driver guy is
working for lalo i don't particularly
think that that's true and i i do agree
that it would have to be a huge retcon
for them to try and make sense out of
how lalo survives how he goes into
hiding why gus eventually thinks that
he's dead so i don't know that that
would be a tall task if they were to
make that a reality
anything on that gill
just that if he dies that was i i guess
i am taking it as a sort of foregone
conclusion even though we don't know it
for a fact
uh but i want it to be as memorable and
visually
uh shocking as gus's death which maybe
it's an unfair expectation but to me he
is
the villain that gus was in breaking bad
that's wallow in better call saul so
he's deserving of a really impressive
death that's what i'm hoping for yeah i
agree 100
i do think that that we will get that
that's what i'm looking forward to
because like you said i and i i've said
this
numerous times some people
don't agree with my point of view on it
but like
he has to die so
i think where what's fun is that they're
going to give us something that matches
what they gave us with gus because gus
was indestructible he was you know you
couldn't imagine how he might lose until
he did so that i feel like we're coming
up for one of those situations with
lollo district
if he gets uh electrocuted that was my
prediction a few weeks back so i just
want that on the record
a little electrocution joe alvarado
thank you for the 4.99 i believe lalo
called hector and told him his plan to
mislead gus
he knew his cover was blown when he
heard the hold music which is why he got
mad yeah that is exactly what happened i
think that that is
a uh uncontroversial take he heard that
there was the phone was being tapped he
realized that he screwed up and then he
composed himself got back on the phone
and
purposely misled uh gus and his men
by telling hector that he was going to
do something that he never planned to do
that he was going to try to hit gus
anyways even though he knew eladio
wouldn't uh
wouldn't be all right with that so i
think that is all of them i tried my
best there was quite a few uh
sorry for the detour for all of you who
came here for a recap but
you know it's part of this it's part of
the experience and we're happy to uh get
to get the questions and have a chance
to think about that stuff in real time
so thank you for those
now the big debate going into this uh
this episode was the
idea of
well this all this setup there was
people were grumbling about the the last
three episodes being slow and you know
things not moving as fast as they would
like and you know the whole idea is is
the setup
is the payoff going to be worth the
setup so what did you guys think did
they did they managed to make it all
worthwhile
gil you can go first sure yeah i mean
you know for me already i i thought that
it was worth the wait and one way i was
thinking about this today
is i think one of the things that we
appreciate about the writers on this
show
is that they are just trying to tell the
best story they can possibly tell
and if you were to take the last four
episodes and just watch them in one go
over the course of three to four hours i
don't think anybody would complain about
the pace
the reason that pacing was so
frustrating is because we have to wait a
week between each episode and
network television worries about that
they try to set up a big cliffhanger
every week they try to make sure that
each individual episode is satisfying on
its own and i'm thankful for the fact
that i don't think they're worrying
about the fact that we need to wait a
week between each episode they're just
trying to tell a great story and there
are things in this episode that i don't
think would have worked as well without
the pay without the setup just a couple
of examples would be the fact that we
knew the drug causes your eyes to dilate
that means that every time we see
howard's face we're checking to see if
those eyes are dilated and that's just
one more ticking time bomb we're aware
of that's one more thing that has us
worried
now you can go back to the last three
episodes and there's always a debate
over how much of it did we need
for example if we took out the scene of
gus cleaning his bathtub would the
payoff have worked just as well maybe
but you never know how much you can take
away
before the impact of this episode would
have been slightly diminished and just
one more thing i'll add is that even
just putting aside the individual
moments that led to the payoff there's
also the fact that it at least lulled me
into a false sense of security it made
me get used to this slower pace
and i walked into this episode doubting
we were going to see a death if these
episodes were moving at a faster clip i
would have said who's dying this week
and i think it wouldn't have landed
quite as well
so
i obviously love this show i'm
completely bought into it so it's hard
to see the flaws so i'll never know how
much of this is me just retroactively
justifying what i saw but at least for
me personally
it was masterfully done the pacing i was
never bored and i thought it set up for
an amazing payoff this episode that i'll
never forget
honestly honestly that was a really good
take kill i i can i agree completely
with you in in regards to if you were to
just binge watch the episodes back to
back you wouldn't really notice anything
and the thing is is i have seen quite a
few complaints in the comments section
of my videos about people saying that
it's too slow that season six isn't as
good as season five and i do think it is
just due to that weekly weight um
personally i think that 604 is maybe the
only one that was a little bit slow but
it makes sense that they had to do a
pallet cleanser after that craziness
that was the nacho arc i think that 605
was as much of a payoff episode as it
was a building episode and then i just
genuinely enjoyed episode 606 as well
and yeah that's the whole thing about
this show right if something crazy was
happening happening every episode then
it wouldn't seem that crazy it's the
fact that it's such a slow burn that
it's so building and and the fact that
it just brings you down to a real level
where these characters feel almost more
and i really love breaking bad too but i
think that this show is even more
relatable just because of showing their
day-to-day life and showing kind of
things on the lesser scale that when
something breaking bad level does happen
it really just blows you away so i do
appreciate sort of the slow build up to
this and i do really think that it pays
off i would like i'm gonna try and uh uh
keep an eye on the chat and uh super
chats and all that to see what other
people think especially people that were
maybe complaining in the last few
episodes i would like to know if
everyone thinks that
this episode was a good payoff because
personally i think it was i think it was
great for a mid-season finale as well
and i'm almost nervous to see the next
episode whenever that happens in like a
month and a half
yeah i think it you know to me it it was
just i mean i agree with what you're
saying but both of you are saying and
then to me it's just a reminder of how
how good these these guys are the
writers the crew everyone involved
they um
they knew what they knew what the what
they wanted to do i mean i think you
could make an argument that they could
have they could have done it in two
episodes instead of three and you know
that
they had them i don't think they wasted
them i think it all comes together in
the end
and i think it's it makes for a a richer
experience when we get there i mean
there's just so many things like this is
like this watching this episode it was
like there was non-stop and we're going
to get into all this so i don't want to
talk about all the different things but
one after the other you just hit with
all these things and they all they're
all they all felt deliberate you know i
mean they all felt like there was a
little setup planted a seed planted back
a few episodes ago or whatever and um
it was it was just i think that i think
that if you if you if you were laboring
through the the weight like you were
saying you know the time in between and
it was really difficult i mean this is a
good example to see why you need to
rethink that idea that if something
crazy
doesn't happen every week then a show
isn't good anymore because you know
they're doing things that that you you
might not understand until you get to
where to where they're going
i d i do really like a comment that i
just saw in the chat that says trust the
process and that's the thing if this was
another show i might be a little bit
worried but i really respect and
appreciate the creators of this show and
i don't have it down in my mind that
they know exactly what they're doing and
they're putting on screen exactly what
they intended
yeah and uh we had a couple of quick
quick uh
question and answer kind of uh super
chats here angelo thank you for the 4.99
confused on h's eyes did substance on
photos cause his eyes to dilate if so
what if they didn't need new photos how
would they get substance to h
well yeah they put it on there you see
them do it in the dark room and that was
always the plan was to put it on the
photos before they gave it to him so
they just would have put it on the old
photos before they switched them out
but yeah it's a it's a topical solution
and he he got that through his fingers
while he was uh touching them
zh
thank you for the five dollars your
opinion on the theory that lydia is the
daughter of peter schuller and a chilean
mother
explaining how this neurotic character
is working with gus
never heard it did either you guys ever
heard this and have a thought about it
i've never heard that theory before
that's interesting i mean she doesn't
really seem german or chilean but i
almost i always am curious in regards to
is this person this person's dad or this
person's son like we heard that cliff's
son had a drug problem i'm wondering who
his son is could it be skinny pete could
it be badger could it be someone else so
i'm always always interested in those
type of theories but no i haven't heard
this at all in regards to lydia
yeah that that whole uh cliff's son
thing became a pretty big topic of
discussion over the last week didn't it
yeah
this i think this is the uh star wars
has trained us to do this every
character
has to be related to somebody and that's
going to be a big revelation later on
but i think they've shown us enough of
lydia's character
and uh kind of her
pragmatism we get a feel for why she
would work in this business so that
theory could be true who knows but i
don't think we need it
yeah that's what i was thinking that was
my
my knee jerk too is that she's already a
well flat uh well fleshed out
interesting character they don't really
need to do too much to to
you know i think that
we already have what we need from lydia
but we'll see i mean i i i do kind of
want to know a little bit more about
schuler and how he ended up getting
involved with gus in in chile but i'm
not sure they're going to go there you
know i think that might be an enduring
mystery
yeah that's that's the whole thing like
after season five especially we were
always wondering like what's the deal
with gus's mysterious past are we gonna
see more in regards to that but season
six really has its own story of its own
i don't i don't know if they have time
for that and if they do maybe they'll
just hint at it once or twice more but i
almost appreciate the mystery for what
it is almost more than getting an
explanation so it would be cool to see
more in that regard but at the same time
if we don't i'm almost completely okay
with it
yeah sir torchington 4.99 again thank
you i agree the slow pace thing is 100
due to streaming and binging i even
watched episode three through six last
week and it already felt more intense
like we're used to
yeah see i'm old and i grew up with the
week to week so that doesn't really
um
always figure into my my consent you
know like my thinking about something
but i do realize that a lot of people
are coming from that perspective
of watching tv
um
you know like and lesser than the lesser
kind of
tons of content just stream through it
don't think that deeply to it just watch
all the episodes in the day and if it's
as long as it you know catches your
interest for a little while then it's
you know it did its job
um this is i feel like this is a you
know this is more of the
of the uh
the old the old style of of making tv
and it's one of the one of the few that
are still out there that are
doing interesting things with it
um there's another one here about the pi
and we're just about to get to that so
i'll wait a second before we pull that
up but that was one of the things that i
really liked about this episode as we've
already touched on was the way that
it answered a lot of the questions that
we had been thinking about and i think
we are in agreement that it was worth
the wait
and that it was
you know
uh satisfying on on on all the in all
the ways that maybe the last few
episodes weren't satisfying in the
moment
and you know one of those things is that
we finally saw d-day and this plan
unfold and um a big part of that was
that the pi was in their pocket the
whole time
um they kind of
they kind of did a little bit of an
exposition dump here with with him
talking to cliff about how that all
played out but it worked so seamlessly
like the two actors really played it off
and
it hits you you're like oh okay i see
how they did that that makes sense it
fits with what kim and jimmy do we saw
them do something similar
whenever they got um
you know where they got mike into to
chuck's house so
so what did you guys think about uh this
this plan
finally seeing it in action
even with the problem of you know having
to reshoot and all that
now that we've been seeing that board
for so many weeks now and chase you can
go first on this one
i uh i i just can't believe how much i
was almost rooting for jimmy and kim for
their plan to go off without a hitch
because the show did do a really good
job at making you feel the tension of
they really need to get this done now
they're paying everyone extra money
they're pulling people from their jobs
from their classes from their plays
they're really doing everything they can
just to get this last moment uh this
last moment con in and it's just the
fact that kim could have gone to that
meeting in santa fe but instead decides
to do this and honestly my heart dropped
and i i already knew that you know the
pi was in on it from the moment that
jimmy gave him the envelope but then
when howard's trying to call him later
on and he just gets you know a blank
dial tone like my heart just dropped
like oh my god i i really went from
almost rooting for jimmy and kim just to
hating them and just feeling so bad for
howard because as howard said in the
episode they played him every step along
the way uh i i do enjoy the fact of how
howard realized what was going on
because to a certain extent if the
viewers know more than the characters do
it can become frustrating so after a
certain point they have to catch the
characters or you know the characters up
to what the viewers know and i think
they did that brilliantly with howard
just instantly putting everything
together and trying to convince cliff
that he's not crazy and i really felt so
bad for howard this episode and that was
before i even knew that he was going to
die so i really think that this is a
chicanery moment uh it's it's definitely
top-notch television i really enjoy it
and just to think that the episode has
so much more to go from there uh it
really is mind-blowing
girl yeah one thing i've been thinking
about a lot these last few episodes is
the
choice that they made to keep us on the
outside of the plan and only give us
certain clues about how it was going to
play out and it's an interesting choice
it's actually not unusual p as you
pointed out previously that's how many
of their cons have worked
but usually we get to pay off the same
episode or the next episode so really
the only difference here is just how
prolonged it was and there's a lot of
fun in that
like the pi moment this episode there
was all the debate is he a double agent
working for jimmy and kim and just like
that we see it come together in this
episode and it's fun to see it come
together the other thing i'm thinking
about one of the things that makes it a
sort of odd choice is that usually when
we watch a show we're anchored with a
character we mostly know what they know
sometimes we get ahead sometimes we're a
little bit behind but in this case it
feels like we've kind of shifted around
where sometimes we're outsiders looking
in on jimmy and kim's plan sometimes
we're more with howard than we are with
them so that's something i'll be paying
attention to when i rewatch these
episodes and just try to understand the
choice as things stand though in terms
of this being the payoff episode there
was a lot of joy and seeing it all come
together i think that's where some of
the laughs came from in the first few
minutes of the episode and to give us
that catharsis of here's the plan
and then follow that up with the
shocking tragedy that we got it all
worked really well so
yeah so all worked well for me and i
want to kind of go back reflect on it
and just think more about the choices
they made
yeah and one of the things i really
liked about about the way they put this
together was that there was that
catharsis but it wasn't celebratory you
know i mean like nobody was really happy
sure kim and jimmy you know they got
what they wanted
but it wasn't you know it i i like the
way that they used uh the judge the way
he reacted
and then and then cliff you know so
we're seeing that through cliff's lens
of like man what did what did i walk
into today i'm just trying to do my
clients you know to get the best deal
for my clients and this guy howard
i i love him but what's going on you
know like he he's just kind of stuck in
this situation
and that was the whole point right that
was the whole point of the way they
planned it out you know howard figures
out what's happening to him but by the
time he does it doesn't matter anymore
it's already slipped away his chance to
to to do it the thing was crafted
so that it didn't matter they he they
knew that he knew that they would figure
out like or that he would figure out
what's going on with them that it was
them doing it
and they just planned enough ahead
so that
this pi it was a complete you know it
was the thing that he couldn't have
anticipated and
so there by the time he does figure it
out it's it's just too late there's
nothing they can do and so like i said i
really liked how they focused on cliff
and how you know
schweikert won
because of it you know what i mean like
he got a better deal he wasn't happy
about it
so you see the in the judge you know he
he kind of had to deal with it but he
wasn't he wasn't you know
he didn't feel vindicated or anything
else you know i mean it was just sort of
like man that was just
hard to watch you know
and uh i really liked how they how they
leaned into that and joe alvarado thank
you for the 999
he said it's funny how when we first
found out the pi we you know about the
pi we thought that howard would die from
lalo by going out and
on his way to investigate and instead we
see
it happen as part of jimmy and kim's
scheme and they drag him in instead yeah
that's something i thought about too
that was the big question about the pi
when he first was hired was like oh no
he's gonna run into mike's guys
turns out that was never even an issue
because um
they hired him in the first place
and i liked how they i'm just going to
say i was just going to say i liked how
they used that that idea of them sitting
outside it was so weird
you're like there's no way they can do
that
but at the same time you're like okay
maybe we just have to
give them that one you know what i mean
and it turned out that they did they did
sit outside and have their wine the
night before because they had nothing to
worry about go ahead chase
oh i just thought it's funny how uh yeah
we did think that howard and the pi kind
of looking into jimmy and kim would uh
uncover some sort of cartel connection
that would get them in trouble maybe
kidnapped maybe killed and then we
learned that the pi was working for
jimmy the whole time so it's like okay
just throw that out the window but then
by the end of the episode howard does
end up getting killed by a cartel member
so it kind of is what we thought but
just not at all in the way that we
thought
yeah
lunar orbit thank you for the canadian
five dollars i'm glad they have some
slower episodes to stretch things out a
bit instead of rushing to the end of the
story like game of thrones did that is a
good point um
if they go too fast people will
definitely complain about that
history will you know we've seen that
historically people don't like it too
fast either
eisenberg nice to see you thanks for the
499 the return of jesse walt has been
teased how do you think they will
introduce them into the bcus universe
any predictions for next season
next season i guess you mean the next
half of the season because there's
there's not another one after this um
we have answered the jesse walt question
many times at this point and i think
it's our universal consensus that they
will
that will be flashed forward so there
will they will actually be in the uh
breaking bad timeline not in the bcs
timeline
and yeah it is funny because imd imdb
had everyone thinking that they were
going to show up in episode seven and
that now has come and gone
so that prediction turned out to be
incorrect do you do either of you guys
really quickly have anything else to add
to this right now so that we can get
back to the story
um as i like i said we have answered
this question several times
i just feel bad for anyone who is
learning from you now for the first time
that there is no
season seven coming for this show
yeah
uh yeah i don't know there's a million
options that how walt and jesse could
appear but i do think that it's most
likely going to be some sort of breaking
bad flash forward a uh missing scene so
to speak kind of like what they did with
el camino i think it's going to be
something like that
yeah and like i said i think that is our
universal cons
consensus so thank you for the question
daniel schuster thank you for the five
pounds i think no one in the cartel
apart from hector ever finds out lola
survived saw kim engineer lalo's death
through mike
but ignacio remains the cover
salkim engineer lalo's death room mike
but ignacio remains the cover hmm
that's something that i hadn't really
thought about too much that saul and kim
might reach out to mike to
double cross lalo
but yeah i do which is interesting but i
do agree that i don't think anyone's
gonna
gonna find out
except for hector
and i i thought that that whole
videotape thing was a little bit
surprising like i don't think that's
ever gonna get to donal audio and i
think i guess they that i was wondering
if they answered that in
in the episode as like well okay well he
found out that his plan is no good so he
decided he's not going to send the tape
what did you think about that chase did
you think that they
they kind of already addressed that or
if that's something that'll be in the
background
i mean that that is a huge question
because did lalo plan on sending that
tape before he went in or because lalo
decided to not actually go to the
laundromat instead go and see jimmy and
kim that he decided not to send that to
donald audio anymore because that's not
his plan anymore uh i do think that if
uh jimmy and kim get mike to kind of
help clean up howard's body that they
will obviously have to tell him about
lalo and then maybe they'll kind of
double cross lalo they'll pretend to
help lala with whatever he wants but
then they'll set up a situation where
maybe mike will kill lalo but the whole
thing about the it wasn't me it wasn't
ignacio line from breaking bad is that
uh i don't think saul ever truly finds
out that lalo really dies and it is
possible to blame a dead man so saul can
find out that nacho dies but i i'm not
sure if he ever finds out that lalo dies
yep and matthew reeves five dollars do
you think we will learn any more about
gus's past before the end
and i think we touched on this a little
bit earlier
i think that
i think it might turn out to be an
enduring mystery gill
now i agree with you it feels like that
feels more like something i would want
rather than need at this point with six
episodes remaining
uh especially considering we've got to
get past breaking bad we've got to get
to gene and see how it all wraps up so i
think unlikely at this point but who
knows maybe some small tidbits will come
out
yeah yeah i agree completely i think we
might get a little hint or two here i
don't think we'll get a full story
though i'm not sure we have time for
that so honestly it might be left a
mystery or maybe some sort of gust-free
netflix movie or something like that i'm
not sure
yep and so okay we've talked about
we've talked about a lot of the stuff
here
we didn't really talk about the setup
before we get to the mediation meeting
and there was a lot of interesting stuff
going on there do you think this is
going to be the last time we see the unm
students i mean i thought this was a
pretty good send-off for them
like i said i felt like the the cam or
the microphone guy was kind of like the
mvp of the episode in some ways and
obviously the whole dark crystal musical
um thing was was great i thought i feel
like this kind of felt like their
send-off what do you guys think about
that
no i agree with you i had the exact same
thought because it felt like we were
spending a little more time with them
than i would have expected at this point
in the final season and it kind of
continued the trend of giving some side
characters a little bit extra to do
if this show indulged itself at all the
last few episodes i would say that's one
area where it did for example giving
bill oakley a little more to do giving
huell a little more to do cliff howard
of course though i would hardly call him
a side character so this did feel to me
like the last
bit of fun we get with the unm students
having said that we do know that saul
has a lot of commercials to make so
maybe they will pop in during a
saul
breaking bad timeline montage possibly
uh yeah i love how you brought that up
because you know i really do hope that
we'll see some sort of recreation of
them helping jimmy create his original
saul goodman commercials and the extra
webisodes and and that sort of thing um
but real quick there was a uh there was
a super chat in regards to how old jesse
pinkman is right now i'm not sure if we
uh talked about that or not yet
um
yeah no worries i just had a little
little something i wanted to add to it
because i actually discussed this during
my whole uh walt and jesse uh theory
video so i just want to add in and say
say that the timeline says that jesse
was born in 1984 he graduated high
school in 2002 so he would have been 18
when he graduated obviously so he's 20
years old right now in 2004 and then
he's 24 years old when breaking bad
starts so
uh but yeah yeah back to the the camera
crew they're honestly i think they're my
favorite side characters like i love how
we see them at least once a season i
love uh
what what's his name josh bayton i think
the the guy with the glasses the actor
that plays him he's probably my favorite
out of the three i love just sort of his
nonchalant sarcastic attitude and i
really enjoy how we got to see more of
him this episode i think it's really
funny how it took six seasons to
actually see him in one of his classes
but it's great to know that that just is
his personality in general you know he's
not just talking that way to jimmy just
because whatever you know screw this guy
he that that's just actually how he is
as a person and i i really enjoy anytime
we see them on screen i definitely think
it is a treat
yeah and i really love the way that they
put this uh you know this ticking clock
scene together and the the whole runner
in the beginning um
where they come in and everybody's you
know the camera's sort of spinning
around and
there was just so much so much good
quality stuff going on here and i
thought it kind of i kind of thought the
whole thing of it of it you know
spinning around and getting tighter and
tighter it sort of matched the you know
the trajectory of the episode and you
see that
that that one or ends with uh kim
tightening up the uh
the cast on his arm
and it's sort of like you know just sort
of the just wrapping the whole story up
together at the end after they get
through this crazy thing and um
also this shot where he's using his
stick or his his boom to uh add a little
bit of cover for the photographs i
thought that was a really great detail
i love that so much i love that how
they're trying to make it seem like the
pi is hiding in a bush or something but
really it's just his boom might with a
branch i i thought that was a really
great touch
yeah me too you have anything to add
there go uh gail
uh just the uh the oner i agree with you
i love that and and part of what i think
makes oners work so well is that when we
see cuts in our mind we kind of fill in
the blanks but when you show a wonder
and you are telling the audience that
all of this is happening in real time i
think it makes it all feel more frantic
because it tells you that all these
crazy things happening
we're not cutting between events in
rapid succession but they are all
actually happening at this rapid pace so
i thought the warner worked really well
to just
make you feel what the characters are
feeling in that scene
yeah it's a great it's they did a great
job with it buy a love three or by love
thank you for the five dollars any
chance that lalo becomes the new cartel
leader don eduardo or don lalo
uh
i'm not sure if you ever saw breaking
bad but um
it would be a spoiler to say if that was
possible or not if you hadn't
do we do we should we say anything else
about this or
i mean i mean am i wrong in assuming
that if you're in this live stream it
should be kind of taken for granted that
you've seen breaking bad
i don't know i'd be very i'd be very
curious to know if there's anybody here
that hasn't seen it
donald audio is a prominent character in
this show breaking bad that is you know
that this is a prequel for so
that that'll that's that's something to
keep in mind when you think about
whether he might or might not become the
leader
thank you though i mean i i don't i i've
i don't i don't i just don't want to
spoil big things if uh if that wasn't
your intention
steve mueller thank you for the 4.99 we
all thought d-day meant doomsday when it
really meant death day side question
what does the vivid kiwi mean go ahead
chase explain that
honestly honestly there isn't much
meaning to it i've always gone by kiwi
uh i used to have other usernames where
i did gameplay videos and stuff like
that so i've always just kind of called
myself kiwi and i i just looked up
little wanted to look up a different
word that would fit well and after about
an hour two i found vivid i thought it
worked well so i don't know not too much
meaning behind it to be honest
cool and yeah d-day uh i i looked up
what d-day the d and d-day actually
meant and it means d-day i mean it means
day um you know it's sort of like a
generic filler for a day that you can't
actually say as you keep it secret or
whatever um
and it did it did actually turn out to
mean death day so thank you for that um
disraeli davis thank you for the five
dollars how many episodes do you think
will remain in the current time frame
i don't know i think we could actually
start to see a blurring of things maybe
some half and halfers and and things
like that um
either one of you got something quick
that you could do you have like an idea
four
four in the current timeline two in in
gene or just two in breaking bad uh two
in a breaking bad slash gene i think we
we kind of fast forward through breaking
bad
and we get to gene
yeah i feel like we kind of need three
to get through lola versus gus
two at minimum
what do you think chase
well i think i think we're definitely
gonna have at least one gene episode at
the end i don't know if we're gonna have
two or not and then in regards to the
breaking bad timeline i don't know if
we're gonna have a full episode i feel
like we might just have another breaking
bad flash forward or two something like
that kind of as a cold open to an
episode so i honestly think that most of
the show is going to be in the better
castle timeline with maybe a breaking
bad flash forward for the uh walton
jesse cameo and then hopefully just a
full final episode with gene
yeah and maclos 31 thank you for the
twenty dollars
five dollars
it's a mysterious post
but i i do appreciate it uh i've been
thinking about it for a second and i
can't come up with anything do you guys
uh have anything to
say about this
maybe he wants five dollars
yes if you guys feel like and you know
how to send mac lows 31 5
sir torchington 4.99 anyone think that
death was almost too graphic lol like a
horror film woke up numerous times last
night with howard's face haunting me
i thought it was pretty tasteful
actually i mean it it was pretty clean
they didn't really linger on anything
how about you uh gil what did you think
uh yeah it didn't strike me as
particularly graphic and maybe just
desensitized based on all the horrible
things we do sometimes see on tv
uh but it was definitely for me the
emotional reaction to it was a lot
harsher than the actual visual it came
off as so frank lalo just shoots him
without a second thought
and you see his head hit the ground so
less it wasn't gory to me but it was
very frank and disturbing in that sense
it did definitely have an effect on me i
didn't have any howard related
nightmares but i had
more than my average share of bizarre
dreams last night and woke up a few
times so it may have been a little bit
more of an emotional rollercoaster than
my mind could handle so i could
definitely relate
yeah i don't know
unless you unless you slow it down like
when i i had to slow it down and kind of
take screenshots for a video um it all
happened so fast you know i was kind of
too busy being shocked in the moment to
really notice too much gore but uh i
will point out that once howard is dead
and he's laying on the ground and you
kind of have a close-up of his face with
his open jaw that is really haunting so
i could see how that would that would
freak you out and leave you a bit
disturbed but i honestly think that the
most gore that we've ever seen on the
show was in the last episode when he cut
off casper's leg like that was pretty
freaking gory uh but yeah yeah the just
the howard death happens so fast that
unless you really slow it down and try
to look at each frame i mean it just
happened so fast it definitely is really
good shock factor uh aside from just his
jaw being open on the floor that is kind
of terrifying not gonna lie
it chases wait a second you're used to
the word haunting i feel like that
perfectly captures that image like i
said before frankly it's just it's so
frank and he hits the ground and that
close up on his face it's like haunting
like perfectly captures it
oh yeah and i think we i think we should
um
just transition into that because we're
at the the 90 minute mark here and
we can go back and talk to about a
couple of other things but
when we're going through these we'll
we'll kind of we'll kind of cover the
you know the that last scene as we go
and you know it
what what you guys were both saying here
the idea of it being haunting and that
was the part that that really
hit me and the reason why we're going to
transition and talking about it was is
that the lead up
first we had the knock on the door and
because of that cockroach you know i was
already thinking wait lalo might show up
here
so it was such a relief whenever it was
actually howard the the first time
and you know that that was completely
unexpected to have that experience to be
like oh thank god it's howard you know
what i mean and then
they ratcheted up the tension with the
with the candle and that lead up i mean
that was that was what was really scary
and then you see their reactions
whenever he comes in whenever they see
him you know we talked about the howl
and like you know jimmy's kind of
stunned look and hit you know how he was
kind of
shocked to see that lala was still alive
but yeah i mean the the killing itself
you know it was it was i thought it was
very true to what you would expect waldo
to do in that situation and it was wild
how
he's so charismatic that he came in
and he he was able to put him at ease
all the way through putting the silencer
on his gun you know what i mean like he
he's he's obviously a menacing human
being
anyone that walks into your house in the
middle of night like that he pulls out a
gun he's putting the silencer on
and there's still a part of howard
that's like wait a minute maybe this guy
is not so bad you know maybe there's
something else going on here that i'm
just not not not getting
he was just so casual about it just so
nonchalant
yeah and he has this huge smile on his
face i mean tony dalton really nailed
like the whole thing i mean this whole
like for one thing patrick fabian
regardless of anything else
he's always been fantastic but
regardless of anything else uh this was
by far
the the greatest performance that that
he's ever put together like i mean he
went to places that that the character's
never gone before and he made every
second of it work
that was re you know that was
returned you know he
bob and ray they were able to return
that and their reactions to what he was
saying
and then like i said tony dalton comes
in and it's just like a master class of
how to be the creepy crazy
villain of the series with a smile on
your face that is enough to you know
kind of catch everybody off guard
i mean that's just really the epitome of
wallows character right like he is so
devilishly dangerous but he always has a
smile on his face but you just know that
those he just has some sharp teeth with
that smile
well kemp stanners thank you for the
five pounds scary how much more chaotic
things would be if the salamancas just
recited the alphabet to hector a couple
of times
communication is the key
yeah he's just out there i mean
you know he's he's kind of a loose end
in in the way that his situation is but
he has his reasons not to
to let everyone know that lalo's out
there at the same time
he's trying to protect his advantage you
know as well that's why he wants them to
get proof
moises
[Music]
499 thank you do you think lola would
use the disappear person and come in the
gene timeline
i i don't really see what motivation he
would have it doesn't seem like lala
goes around worrying about whether he's
gonna die or not you know he he seems
like the kind of character who
he's he's on a path uh you know it's not
he's not really out for survival he's
out to like win the game
do you have anything on that gill
just that he doesn't strike me as the
kind of person who would choose to
disappear uh i mean ever just seconding
everything you said
ye thank you for the five dollars i
watched bcs before watching breaking bad
i absolutely love how the first season
complements it like the drug bust in
episode 1 on the tv even down to the
dollar amount
yeah i i remember this was a thing
whenever that happened um
i i i'm a little bit confused on i mean
the timelines don't really match up for
that and
i think that's what you're going for i'm
a little bit confused on what you're
talking about but
uh
they do
they do
they do write things in a way that they
you know that they work together
and that there's a consistency
throughout the universe
so i i definitely agree with you on that
that
it's it's
they do a fantastic job even whenever
things don't
you know
directly influence each other
jack larkin thank you for the 499 any
theory theories on lala's plan with
jimmy and kim what information can he
get from them that will benefit him
right now
it's a good question i i this is the
question i posed at the end of my video
this week is like what is he actually
trying to do um
they're an asset there's someone he can
use uh that that part is clear like you
know you understand why he's there but
um
it's a little hard to speculate on where
things go from here chase did you have
something that you had in mind about
that
honestly i was trying to think back to
the things that jimmy and kim even know
and they don't even really know do do
they know that it was juan balsa that
set up the the men to try and hijack
jimmy
uh because that's honestly one of the
only things i could think of i mean they
know about how mike
helps save his life and and all of that
but that that's really about it honestly
so unless he can sort of link juan balsa
back to trying to screw him over i'm not
too sure it's honestly something that's
kind of making me scratch my head i'm
gonna have to think a little bit to try
and come up with some theories here
yeah do you have anything gill because i
think that's where i'm at too it's just
i'm waiting to see what happens next
yeah the only thought i have in addition
to what you guys already said is maybe
he's not after information
but he is clearly suspicious that jimmy
was helped in the desert and if he
thinks that jimmy has a connection to
mike and therefore gus he might want to
use him as a sort of double agent what
if he says kim why don't you stay here
with me jimmy i need you to go
find mike and do something for me and
maybe get me some information
or or who knows what it might entail
um but that's the only other only other
place my mind has gone um besides just
trying to get info from them
i i just saw a comment in the chat
saying that uh
uh mike told kim that he knows that lalo
was alive so the only thing i could
think of is that you know uh they could
tell wallow that mike and gus knows that
he's alive but he already kind of knows
that because he knows that they were
waiting for him at the laundromat
true
uh yeah by the way uh sorry i have an
early flight tomorrow so i'll probably
stick around for about five more minutes
but then i'm gonna have to bow out
okay thanks for letting us know just let
me know when you want to go and we'll
let you uh
plug your stuff and say goodbye
okay wallace and abro and i should have
obviously said that wrong thank you
don't you think the unm guys could come
back and shoot an earlier version of
saul's commercials yeah that's what uh
gill was brought up at the end of that
so
i i don't know if you have anything else
to add but i think that yeah that's a
that's a
that's a good idea i agree
and yeah just to go back to the last one
i mean the idea of what what what
lalo might want i think that that's you
know what you're what you're talking
about there is important because i've
heard them say that
lalo didn't leave satisfied that jimmy
didn't have anything
going on he just had other things he
needed to do that that took precedence
to hanging around and trying to
interrogate him so i think there is an
open-ended thing in his head where he's
wondering
what really happened that day and what
how can i use that to my advantage so i
agree with what you were saying there
gil
louis rmj thank you for the 10 pounds i
feel sad after that scene with the new
hhm employee not knowing who chuck was
only like a year after his death showing
how howard will just be forgotten
and yeah this is something that i
brought up in my video
i thought that was foreshadowing that
earlier you know that that he already
didn't know i mean he he knew he knows
the name but he didn't know what who
chuck was to see him
and part of that's because of the way
that that chuck left the firm so it
definitely made that whole thing feel
ominous that that howard was being set
up to be forced out in the same way and
like i said i think that you know i
agree that they they crafted this this
whole story about him being an addict so
well
that people are going to that's what
that's going to be his legacy you know
whether he disappears or they make it
look like he killed himself or anything
else
people are going to think of him as the
guy who had everything and threw it all
away because of his drug addiction and
then and then died you know what i mean
it it crushed me when they were talking
about chuck and howard said the line uh
when the kids said you know i hope one
day i can be remembered like chuck as
this you know genius in in the law and
howard says maybe there are more
important things so they've been
spending the last few episodes kind of
cranking up our sympathy for howard and
that really added a lot for me to know
that he's
living with such regret which we kind of
already suspected i i think it was
pretty clear that he was not happy with
the fact that he put so much into his
career and it seems to have cost him his
wife
but to actually hear him say it out loud
and make it so clear the regret that he
died with
yeah that that really got to me
yeah that was one of the most humanizing
moments for for for howard i agree with
that
you have anything you want to add chase
i'm just trying to think of uh how much
of a of a turnover they have over at hhm
and uh exactly how new that guy is that
he doesn't know the original three
founders of the firm that he's working
at but uh it does yeah it does uh
devastate me knowing that uh howard's
legacy will never be brought to justice
and that he'll be remembered in sort of
a bad sense the way that chuck went out
and it really is tragic because howard
knows the truth uh and even if cliff
does um you know he's still unsure about
the whole situation so who knows if he's
really going to uh
uh vindicate the the whole situation or
if it's just going to be left as is
i think you just triggered a thought
from me chase and uh this will be my my
last thoughts before i before i sign up
sign off and finish packing
but one thing i would love
is if in the gene timeline
what if we see him try to set things
right what if he calls cheryl and he
says there's something you should know
about howard or somehow gets word out if
he's sort of reckoning with himself and
wants to make some sort of amends so you
just triggered that thought for me and
that's something uh i don't know how
likely it is but that would be pretty
nice to see
yeah that is an interesting theory
especially if gene decides to come clean
and he we get the whole theory where he
decides to turn himself in or just kind
of uh repent for uh all of his sins i
suppose
[Music]
yeah i'm looking forward to thinking
about all of those kinds of things for
the next six weeks because yeah there's
a lot of interesting things there so
you're getting ready to take off yeah so
i'll head out uh pete thank you again
for having me on and having me on for
the last few weeks these streams have
been a lot of fun
uh i
i've been i've been spending a lot of
time talking about better call saul but
i love the fact that the show gives us
so much to talk about and there's such
an awesome community of people to talk
about it with including you pete and
chase and everybody in the chat so uh
look forward to doing more of these
maybe a few during the break and then of
course when we get back for the second
half
yeah we'll be in touch about uh what to
do in that than that downtime i'm really
not sure um
i'm going to be shifting to coverage of
forum for all mankind but that's not
going to take up the same amount of time
as as this does and i definitely want to
you know
i'll be thinking about this as much as
as as anything else so we'll we'll we'll
look into keeping that going or what
that looks like or whatever and uh i
just want to thank you yeah this has
been a great
uh six weeks i guess we did it there
were seven episodes we did in six weeks
and it's been a lot of fun
and uh it wouldn't have been the same
without you so
let's talk soon sounds good talk to you
soon take care everyone have a good one
you too
okay william thank you for the five
dollars lalo kidnaps saul to get to mike
kim contacts d.a lalo dies at the hands
of pd
kim gets witness protection and saul's
image at court recovers
would we say that his his his image was
was recovered i mean i i don't know a
lot of what i think about now
has been colored by that american greed
segment that they did and the way that
it just was such a compelling
version of the story you know what i
mean
yeah it's been a huge debate on whether
that american greed moment or special is
canon uh personally i think that it is
but just the one thing that irks me is
in regards to lalo having that
conversation with jimmy uh in the
when he was in jail like that was
apparently that conversation was
apparently recorded so unless lalo is
somehow a rat or something like that i'm
not quite sure how that could exactly
make sense but i do hope that we get uh
maybe a second part to the american
greed maybe during the break or after
season six because the way that that
video ended it kind of seemed like they
were just going to commercial break and
that they were gonna come back for
another segment it didn't really feel
like a true ending
and as far as kim getting witness
protection uh i'm not sure if it's gonna
be legitimate witness protection if
we're talking about
ed the vacuum cleaner
it is a huge question for me if we're
actually going to see someone uh
disappear via ed in the better call cell
timeline because i do think it's great
that they showed the origins of jimmy
getting ed's card i think it ties well
uh to the 405 flash forward of jimmy
calling ed and wanting to disappear and
of course relating back to the
gene timelines and actually getting to
see ed in that timeline and so i i do
think on one hand that they just kind of
put that in so that better call saul has
a standalone explanation of who ed is
and how jimmy got that contact so i do
wonder if that's going to be it for that
or if we are going to see kim or someone
else actually disappear
yeah i've been thinking about that a lot
the last couple of weeks too because as
we're seeing kim being more
as we're getting to learn more about her
character and realizing that it's a bit
darker than than we maybe had
anticipated
it you know it's like
would she still go to jail like the idea
of her going to prison was always like
that she would take responsibility for
whatever thing happened you know like
because because she's that kind of
person it turns out she's not really
that kind of person maybe
you know
so i think that the the biggest the
biggest
the biggest thing that people had a
problem with as far as her using the
disappear was that it's been used so
many times before
it's actually never been used and better
called saul though so like you said
there's a reason for someone to use him
in this series that would set it up for
later
and yeah i don't know one thing that
jumps out to me here is lalo kidnapping
saul to get to mike and when i when i
when i watched the episode originally i
thought about the fact that he says
michael whenever he sees him and he and
i i was thinking about him of him being
like
worried because all these people were
responding
but i think that that does
the more i think about that as time
passes
his keying in on mike and trying to find
a connection
it does bring him in contact you know
that's the one person that that saul has
in common is as mike and uh you know
he's or he's the one that's in common
between those two people mike and lalo
yeah and that's the whole thing about uh
kim going to jail i mean i always
thought that if she did go to jail if
she did get disbarred it wouldn't be by
choice but now i am wondering if she
does take the fall for howard's death if
they somehow do get caught and they
can't cover it up
yeah lucas stewart 999 says does anyone
really care if the lalo ignacio line
from breaking bad perfectly lines up
with bcs people are too hung up on it in
my opinion
too many other things to worry about
wrapping up i mean i kind of understand
the sentiment people um
people do talk about this a lot i i
guess where i get frustrated is when
people say that lalo has to be alive
because jimmy thinks he's alive
when there's obviously
counter evidence to that that makes more
sense like it's
it's totally believable that jimmy just
doesn't know that lalo's dead um but i
mean the thing about it is i think
what's impressive about this is that
they built this whole storyline off of
this throwaway line
and i think for that reason they will
make it all make sense but i don't think
it has to be in some kind of dramatic
fashion i just think that you know
there's a couple of it's already almost
there so there's a couple of things that
have to
that they have to mention to make it all
make sense whenever he shows up in the
uh desert yeah i think there are only a
few more moments that we need in order
for this to make sense i mean it is
possible that we are overthinking it i
do think that maybe the answer is a
little bit more simple than we think i
don't think it's necessarily going to be
answered on this grandiose scale but i
do think that
they are going to make it line up with
with what saul said in the desert
because that was the creation of the
characters and i do think that they have
to make that make sense just like how
they answered how uh jimmy gets at the
disappears card without mike knowing
there are certain moments in this story
that they know they have to clear up and
i think that is one of them
yeah and bio love thank you for the ten
dollars and sorry if we misunderstood
what you were saying
he clarifies that he has seen seen
breaking bad
he promises that he's not an idiot and
laughs i was thinking there was a very
small chance lalo doesn't die and goes
into hiding for the next few years
then fills in after the events of
breaking bad
now your question makes sense and uh
sorry that i didn't put all that
together
before i i don't know i mean it's it's
technically possible as you point out um
i just think that for me i don't expect
him to survive i expect him to
take gus on
and lose
that just seems like an inevitability in
a lot of ways but there are you know
that
now that we're getting there now that
everybody is dying
it at once feels like kim might have has
more of a chance to die and that lalo
has less for just because you know you
don't really know they're not really
holding our hand and taking us to the
place they're making us wonder how it
might turn out
and i did notice that after howard died
i'm thinking okay well i didn't really
think kim would die before but now maybe
she might and then i was sure that lala
was gonna die and now maybe he won't you
know so there's a lot of fun stuff going
on there there's a lot of stuff going
going on there uh there is a void there
is i mean somebody stepped in for a
latio it's just someone that that gus is
not um
i mean there was i guess there would be
warring factions or whatever that the
void would be filled it's just gus got
out of it by taking out all those people
on that day
um do you have anything that you want to
add to this chase
uh honestly i was just about to say uh
what you just ended off that thought
with uh yeah there is a void there is
someone else that could step in because
when you think about it all the style
monkeys are dead that we know of all the
cartel leaders not just eladio but all
of his other right hand men and then gus
was supposed to take that over but now
he's obviously dead too walt tried
taking over the business with mike and
jesse that didn't end up turning out so
well so there is a void that needs to be
filled i don't think it will necessarily
be lalo i mean if he did survive then
potentially but i am kind of still in
the boat that we're going to see lalo
die in the next few episodes
yeah and you know that
what i was what i was thinking about
with the uh
with the void is that
you know
gus was meticulous in taking out
everyone that was important
so there's not really something that
lalo could actually walk right back into
that's the thing i guess you would you
would think about you know he can't just
he just can't come in and the entire
organization is there waiting for him
you know
he would have to actually probably go to
war with other rival cartels that were
trying to take over that that thing and
i mean what would he if he's been in
hiding for a few years how much of a
chance would he actually have to do
something like that yeah i feel like
hypotheti i feel like hypothetically one
of the other uh mexican cartels that we
just don't know about will just take
over that territory and go from there
yeah i think that was gus's plan dan
parker thank you for the five dollars
howard and all those arcs mirrored each
other this season
both set up by people both both making a
case against them
ended up in the same place same time
yeah there was a real um sense of
you know
that
they both they both did have a adversary
who drove everything that happened to
them
um do you got anything that you want to
add i mean this is this is more of a
statement than a question but it's it's
i get what what they're saying it does
there is a nice mirroring there do you
want to add anything about that
oh no not necessarily i get the parallel
it is a good point but i don't really
have much to add to it to be
honest cool
chris h thank you for the 199. any
chance uh hank shows up
takes lalo into custody um
really no mention of dean norris showing
up in this in this season
and last year they tipped their hat on
it eventually so i'm not really
expecting are you expecting them to show
up chase i mean it's definitely possible
he exists in the universe he's out there
but what do you think
i mean it is kind of possible i kind of
hope to for it to be honest uh back in
the season six trailers when we saw uh
bulsa's men opening the safe there was
actually one henchman that kind of
looked like pink to me turned out to not
be him was a little bit of a
disappointment but yeah i feel like in
season five they really they showed hank
in the trailers it was gonna be a big
thing he was cameoing in i was hoping he
was gonna be more of a regular on the
show but i guess it was just those few
season five episodes and i think they're
kind of hyping up walt and jesse for
this season the same way that they did
hank last season so sadly i i don't
think we're gonna see hank again but it
would always be a pleasant surprise
absolutely professor g thank you for the
five dollars howard's death reminded me
of hanks
speaking of hank the look on jimmy kim's
face was like waltz
kim is in it now
those are all true statements professor
g and uh yeah that that hit me right
away too um
i saw a lot of people you know making
ozymandias uh comparisons they're
they're right there for the taking right
there for the making um
and yeah i mean
i uh one other thing like i mentioned it
briefly earlier but i i did think that
the performances here were
some of the best we've seen and um
that is also true of whenever you know
walt walt sees that happen to hank do
you have anything you want to add to
this one chase
oh yeah there's definitely a lot of
parallels you can make between hank's
death and howard's death one
specifically that i saw
in the comments in my video is that uh
hank tells walt that he's you know the
smartest person that he's ever known but
he can't see the obvious and then howard
kind of compliments kim in the same way
during his final moments and just uh you
know in regards just how shocked jimmy
and kim are i really think that that was
just amazing acting from how terrified
jimmy is when lalo first appears to the
just their blood-curdling shriek when
you know the deed is done there's
definitely a lot of parallels you can
put between those two deaths except for
the fact that uh
howard is completely innocent you know
he wasn't in the game at all i mean i
guess
hank was kind of adjacent to the game
but he kind of uh accepted the terms of
service so to speak in regards to
knowing what he was getting himself into
but it was just a complete surprise for
howard
yeah
yeah i agree completely jay wilkes thank
you for the five dollars we do all keep
assuming that if lalo dies
gus's crew is responsible
however he is crossing the cartel acting
on his own they could easily kill him
that's true
that is absolutely true
they could just decide to
uh
you know
take him out because he's not following
their their uh you know with their
orders but
i don't know that that would have the
same amount of i mean there's a lot of
potential
drama between him and and gus having a
showdown i don't know if that's there if
we're thinking about the cartel
i mean uh el audio is really just
keeping gus alive because he's an earner
and also because of his past but you
definitely get sort of the contention
that they don't really they don't really
like gus and although
although eladio does sort of uh stir the
pot in regards to gus versus the
salamancas because back in uh season
three the episode sabasito i believe you
know eladio is kind of shoving in
hector's face that gus is earning more
than him so i feel like it's kind of
indifferent to el adio but just
considering that lalo is a salamanca i
feel like they'd probably take his side
over anything but i mean it is a
possibility
yep and jacob bereas 4.99 thank you do
you think kim could break bad even more
than she already has
or will she regress from this moment i
don't think that there's really any
going back
i think that her story has some momentum
and and that she is going to
stay in there for no other reason is
because of of lalo's introduction here i
mean there
he he kind of changed everything like
they can't just
they they're they're they're in it like
they can't really just walk away from it
like they could have maybe
one episode before
yeah
i do think that uh kim kind of sealed
her fate when she did that u-turn
deciding to go back down bad choice road
and honestly i think that the theory of
kim might start working for lalo is kind
of a possibility because she talked lalo
down the first time he went to their
apartment and if they're able to talk
him down again maybe she will sign
herself up for working for him and kind
of replace jimmy but say it kind of in a
similar way in breaking bad where jesse
would work for gus but only if he
doesn't kill walt i could see kim
working for lalo but only if he doesn't
kill jimmy so i don't know who knows kim
could be a cartel lawyer or put her
skills to use in regards to being a con
artist
yeah i think lala's going to be dead so
there won't be anybody to work for but
that's
possible you know
that that i mean that's that's been a
long time theory also just like
lalo killing howard that and that didn't
really seem like it was gonna happen but
it actually did just the last just
yesterday
slanted mott
i don't know
two words in a row i still don't know
how to uh
pronounce
thank you for the canadian 699 and i
don't mean to make fun of your your
screen name here especially if it's your
real name i just i look at those two
words and i'm really having a hard time
figuring out how to uh pronounce them
a little off topic but do you think
we'll finally see the often mentioned
judge pompadou pompadumian before the
series ends uh i've i've seen people
bring this up quite a bit in the
comments like we have to see judge this
judge before the series ends it's never
been something that's been a burning
issue for me
how about you chase
uh could you refresh my memory on who
this guy even is honestly
uh
jamie mentions that they like his
clothing
you know what i mean i think it's a she
uh and he brings it up to kim you know
whenever he wears something kind of
ridiculous he says oh i'm going in front
of judge papadumia and and they they
like my style or whatever is that's the
sentiment you know what i mean
okay yeah no i honestly i ain't got a
take on that sorry
yeah it's sort of a throwaway thing but
it's been mentioned enough times that i
understand where you're coming from with
this question i think it would be funny
i don't know if we're going back to the
courtroom and based on the current
trajec
trajectory of things but we'll see
sir torchington thank you again for the
199 random thought candle flicker equals
ghost
yeah and
that's what i was saying that it it
totally is like jimmy seeing a ghost and
i like the way that they use that
flicker just to make it clear if i if i
haven't said that
recently
mod mary thank you for the 4.99 kim is
by far the most complex character in the
show
i hope to get a big wow moment for her
arc
will she tell jimmy that she knew about
lalo yeah i think that she'll have to
but it's interesting to think about if
she doesn't you know if she keeps going
with that because it's going to start to
burn up our her currency with us
if she starts to even in the face of the
truth being out there
choose to lie to jimmy at this point in
the story would you agree with that
chase
yeah i mean this is this could be a huge
conversation in regards to
to the drama between their relationship
i mean it could be the thing that breaks
them up i think it will be a bit less
bad if kim admits to jimmy that she knew
instead of mike getting involved and
then he tells jimmy that he met up with
kim because jimmy doesn't even know
about any of that but i am really
interested to see in what sort of
circumstances uh they're gonna let jimmy
know that kim did know lala was alive
and it was fairly irresponsible for him
for her to not tell him because i i
don't know i guess she just thought that
mike's men would be able to keep watch
over them or she thought that she could
take care of lalo
lalo herself but you know it's equal
possibility that law would confront
jimmy as it is her along with them
together so uh you know kim was
surprised in this final moment in this
episode but definitely not as surprised
as jimmy and you can really see that in
the acting i think they did a great job
showing that
yeah and i think um
you know to go back to the question
yes i think she will
tell him
um
and what what i thought stood out to me
as far as her character here that came
out was
when
howard says you've got a piece missing i
think it's the way that he put it but
basically there's something off
everything is everything appears to be
working perfectly she's the brightest
person with
most promising you know smartest person
that he's known
but she's got a piece missing
and what i thought stood out to me about
that was that it felt like
he was seeing something about her that
she knew was there
you know what i mean like you know when
the way that their exchange went down it
looked like
she understood this and then you have to
ask yourself what is it
and why does she
choose not to look at it why does she
why is this something that's just there
that
that she allows to uh you know kind of
drive her but we never really noticed
that or understood anything about that
before this you know
i mean she's always been a little bit in
over her head from going and actually
confronting wallow in jail to
uh standing up for jimmy and i mean she
did end up saving jimmy's life in
episode 509 but she always is a little
bit in over her head and i think that
you know seeing howard get killed right
in front of them has really solidified
the seriousness of the situation and the
danger that is lalo and the cartel so
maybe this will knock her down a peg i'm
not sure we'll have to see
yeah for me it was more of a situation
about control you know they they
actually planned this out that it it
worked flawlessly
even though it pissed howard off he he
acknowledged the fact that he would
actually bounce back that he would be
okay he was humiliated but he would
eventually
return to where he was because that's
where his that's his position you know
what i mean he has that kind of of a
situation he was in no way ruined
and that was exactly how they had
planned it out they wanted him to look
bad they wanted him to feel bad
they wanted to get the money
but
they didn't want to ruin his career and
then
all of that planning you know because of
of their previous things the previous
things that jimmy did whenever he
decided to go and be the bag man
there was unforeseen
you know consequences and unintended for
sure and
that's just that's just the way that
life works you know i mean you can plan
things out all you want and something
always is always possible for something
to go wrong here because of the stakes
of him becoming a friend of the cartel
the stakes are you know howard loses his
life for being in the wrong place at the
wrong time
yeah exactly
i agree completely
so colin wallace thank you for five
dollars what are you guys preferences
predictions when it comes to kim one
dying two getting disappeared or three
dying
um
i'm leaning more towards getting
disappeared than i ever have
over the last couple of episodes but i'm
gonna be i'm gonna personally be looking
at that for my next video so
i'll have to see where i land
what do you think chase
uh honestly there there are so many
different possibilities with what could
happen to kim uh
you know is she still with saul and
breaking bad are they divorced does she
go off on her own and have her own
successful career does she get to spart
and go to jail
um i i think that you know this show or
this universe always goes for kind of a
bittersweet ending and i think that her
dying would even though you know earlier
in in the stream i was saying that it is
very possible that she could not leave
this apartment alive i do still stand by
the fact that i think saul is too cheery
in breaking bad for her to her to
actually be dead or else he would just
be mopey and depressed all the time and
he's always joking about women you know
commenting about francesca so i don't
think that she's still in his life and
something that could be even worse than
her dying is her getting disbarred and
going to jail because what if she gets
the sandpiper money but she's in jail so
she can't enjoy it
yeah and i think that um you know we
we've obviously touched on this in the
past and it's one of those things that
it just changes you know it's really
hard to to
actually
land on one because they did a really
good job of setting things up to where
it could go
either way you know
yeah yeah there's so many different
possibilities we just got to see which
one they choose
yeah angelo 199 thank you gus tells
hector the salamanca name dies with him
he definitely does that that's the uh
that's the counter argument to everyone
who says that
jimmy believes lalo is still
the garden alive
eden
go ahead
i was gonna say yeah that's a very
important moment it's always in the back
of my head
yeah and you have to imagine that guts
knows more than i mean you should think
that gus knows more than than jimmy does
so
yeah that's why that's why all of this
that's why lala's surviving seems so
impossible
only thing that you know like i said
it's now it's starting to feel like okay
well maybe they're going to take that as
a challenge and try to make that make
sense
because if anybody could write that this
team of writers could you know
yeah it's just after so many episodes of
gus being paranoid about lalo being
alive is he really just gonna let that
go without knowing for sure that he's
dead
i definitely don't think so garden of
weed and thank you for the 499 i think
the way that lalo is written makes him
seem like an anime villain this is why
it's hard to believe gus gets the better
of him
well i mean it's the same thing with gus
in in breaking bad he was he was such a
you know he's such a menacing character
that you couldn't imagine
that walt would get the best of him
either you know what i mean
yeah i mean with how with how smart uh
lalo is he definitely is a formidable
foe for gus and i love how they match
them against each other in the show
because it really does give gus
something to do but i still always go
back to the saying that uh gus is
playing chess and lawless playing
checkers so and we all we obviously know
breaking bad so we'll just have to wait
and see
yeah do you have anything on the anime
billion villain aspect of it because i'm
i'm not a big anime watcher
oh you're muted i don't know maybe
you're having some mic trouble there um
riley cool thank you for the five
dollars another timeline question when
in time is the ostentation mansion post
breaking bad pre-gene
yes
post-breaking bad um obviously walter
has been taken off the the board and
they are um
you know they're they're
they're doing an investigation of some
sort whenever they do that and it would
be
it would be parallel with gene as far as
he's already been disappeared but
not not yet
you know we haven't gotten to the scenes
of gene that we saw yet if that makes
sense
those are a bit in the future i believe
bob condon thank you for the seven
dollars and thirty cents i know this
goes back in the season
but i don't know if you're if you've
covered it how does gus explain
capturing nacho why no suspicion
um they never did actually
make this clear
i can't think of anything that explains
it other than
everyone was looking for him
are you back chase
hmm
yeah i i don't i don't know if i if i
can think of something i'll i'll bring
it up but i i don't think that they ever
directly address this
okay
oh there we go
no i i'm not sure if that was you or me
it could have been me because i'm going
off a wi-fi right now i think my uh my
internet browser just crashed but i i
think i'm back now so sorry about that
yeah i heard i heard the sound that your
your connection was a little bit weak
right before that your your mic kind of
broke up a little bit and then it cut
out so that's what i figured happened
yeah yeah sorry for the disruption but
yeah i think i think just my whole
firefox just crashed there so i just had
to restart but hopefully smooth sailing
from here on out
do you have anything about this about
why uh gus
capturing nacho wasn't a big deal
oh that i honestly think that's kind of
a plot hole like i would love to know
more about that because yeah they did
beat him up to you know make it seem
realistic but the salamanca twins were
chasing after him and then suddenly he
escapes and now gus has them all of a
sudden it just seems a little bit a
little bit too good to be true but there
there is a lot about the the nacho
aftermath that i would have liked to see
in regards to explaining how gus uh
captured nacho uh maybe seeing mike
barry nacho where the blue flower uh
blooms uh i don't know i feel like they
just kind of you know
smacked their hands and uh
and just moved on
yeah angus evans thank you for the
australian five dollars well peter
schuller and or lydia show up in the
last six episodes they hinted at gus's
backstory in chile will we meet these
characters again
this is a question that we answered a
bit earlier and the consensus was that
lydia was a pretty complete character
there wasn't much that we needed to much
more that we really need to learn about
her i mean of course it's always welcome
she's an enjoyable character
and that gus's backstory in chile
is likely to be a
enduring mystery unless there's a plot
reason that they have to visit that i
don't think this is a loose end that
they need to tie up just because
you know it's a thing i think there
there's a we we all agreed that there
was a you know there's something good
about having keeping it a mystery so
that you continue to think about it
big mac double
big mac 076 thank you for the 4.99 any
thoughts on why they bothered to show us
what seems to be the pi
following kim jimmy at the end of
episode two that was mike's guys that
was following them and that's how the
whole thing happened where kim and mike
met for the first time
so
it was a misdirect to make us think that
howard had hired a pi because of the
trailers and stuff like that but no that
was always supposed to be mike's guys
that were following him there
all right scrolling scrolling scrolling
uh david roberts thank you for the five
dollars what could the nebraska couple
possibly gain from badgering gene that
would
exceed the incentive of simply correct
simply collecting the five million
dollar reward
uh that's a teaser thing that five
million dollar reward i don't know that
we've ever
seen that verified that that exists in
the real
universe did you have a feeling about
that um chase
i mean i i always thought that that was
canon just because we saw gene walk back
walk past and pull off the poster but
there's a chance that it's not because a
lot of the uh a lot of the posters
surrounding it uh are from local
albuquerque parks or businesses so is
that sort of implying that jean's back
in albuquerque is this actually in his
mall where his cinnabon is uh it's
entirely possible that that teaser could
just not be canon at all but i always i
always kind of took it with a grain of
salt but i i don't know i am kind of
leaning towards it being canon um and in
regards to him being wanted i mean we
did see that uh jesse pinkman was kind
of you know a most wanted criminal in el
camino so i think that's all could be
kind of the same in that regard
yeah and i don't know i
um i i do i mean that the definitely the
bulletin boards in albuquerque so if
that's real if that if that um
you know if that is like a
thing that's still going on that there's
this reward that's out there
it is hard to square
why
jeff is uh you know not trying to
collect it or what's his angle you know
what i mean he he could collect it
otherwise
um and i don't know the answer to that
so thank you for the question
big ralph thank you for the one dollar
that one we already answered
nate thank you for the 4.99
thanks for for all of the questions guys
it's a
it's a busy night in chat over here i'm
trying to get to all of them
i think chase has stepped away again so
you just have to bear with me
thank you for the 149.
half court
thank you for the ten dollars cal
calhoun
here we go
richie mc five dollars any chance the
writers will make kim pregnant or would
that be lazy writing
lyle lives on forever
what are your thoughts on on a pregnancy
i uh i never once uh considered that but
that would be crazy if they had a con
baby
hmm
yeah it's not something i have
it's weirdly it's not something that i
ever thought about either
i mean they haven't really made it they
haven't really made it a point of
interest but you know the only times we
do ever see them get it together is when
they get excited from a cons such as
howard said you know they get off to it
so
i i don't know that that kid would
definitely lead an interesting life uh i
don't i don't think saul ever mentioned
having a kid or anything like that and
breaking bad so i feel like he he might
have if if that were the case
yeah that's that's absolutely true um
sorry i was just looking through here
that there's a little bit of
we should we probably could use a
moderator here but i don't know what to
do about that in the moment here uh
angelo thank you for the 499. how long
after breaking bad do you think the gene
scenes take place i think he has less
hair on his head which means he could
have gotten a few years older well he
wears a hair piece in breaking bad right
um i mean he's bald he just he just he
saul goodman just wears a toupee
yeah yeah yeah definitely
but
he does look older
um i i believe it
my my thinking is because of the license
plates and stuff it's a couple years
after you know it's long after
the events of
the finale of breaking bad
some people
like to think that it might be that
there might be some overlap
that walt might be able to stop by in
omaha on his way back to albuquerque and
but um
i don't believe that's the case i think
it's a couple years right
honestly don't remember i know in uh the
g the season four or five gene scene
whenever gene does go out of town and he
kind of he kind of skips the the country
and goes over to to the next town or
sorry state my bad i know i know we saw
uh on the license plate uh what year it
is i just i just can't remember off the
top of my head to be honest but i i'm
pretty sure it's there somewhere
yeah i mean it
he
he leaves in 2010
and
my
my thought was that it was like 2012 but
i'd have to go back and look and i can't
do that right at this moment
okay
half court i think the nba payoff
i think the finale payoff has to be a
breaking bad impacting twist not just
the bcs twist
thoughts thank you for the 7.99
i don't think that it has to be a
breaking bad impacting twist in the
sense that
i mean i think we you know the idea is
that we'll look at it differently
but i don't think that there has to be
something that's that's heavily plot
oriented you know what i mean i mean it
could be just like small little things
such as uh you know lalo lalo's body
being in the south wall so every time
you look at the super lab and breaking
bad you're thinking of oh lala was
actually there the whole time oh the fly
is lala or just some silly thing like
that but i don't really think they're
gonna do some sort of huge retcon that
will completely change the outlook of
breaking bad because they have talked
about previously how difficult it is to
make a prequel working in the confines
of the universe that they've already
created so they definitely are really
careful with how they go about things
like that and any they might add
complementary you know sort of tidbits
but i don't think it's gonna just
revolutionize breaking bad as we know it
yeah that's the way i think about it too
and i'm not even sure that there's going
to be a twist
you know this this this question points
out the idea of a twist i don't think
it's really a twisty show so much as
they'll do a good job of of delivering
the thing that makes the most sense and
still making it exciting you know i mean
even though we might be able to figure
out where it's going i mean that that's
what that's what's been impressing me
for the you know this throughout this
episode and this in particular this
payoff in this in this uh episode here
yeah i agree
so i guess um
what else haven't we talked about is
there anything else you want to talk
about in the episode that we didn't get
to yet
uh i mean we could we kind of did have a
have a disjointed way of going about
everything i mean we talked about
talked about everything with the camera
crew in the in the mediation uh howard
figuring it out but it being too late
lalo's plans switching up and then
everything with uh with howard in the
aftermath in regards to that i'm not i'm
not too sure if there's uh
anything else we can we can touch on
honestly i'm still pretty speechless
about the episode like it was
it was it was a little bit difficult to
uh to to even make my videos in regards
to it because i'm just in such shock and
awe i feel like i even need i feel like
i even need a few more days to process
what i just saw
yeah that's um
that's definitely the kind of episode it
was you know like there's i feel like
there's going to be more that sinks in
the more that that we sit with it
nafe thank you for the 4.99 i forgot
adding question do you guys sympathize
with jimmy and kim as they evolve and
break bad like we did with walter
or am i the only one who does not i
don't think you're the only one but i do
i sympathize with them
um
i think that this is that was one of the
things i wanted to talk about and you
know it whenever howard you know did his
information dump you know whenever he
sort of pointed out all their reasons
and then he sort of got to the point
that they do it for fun
and that they get off on it and that you
know there's something missing in their
characters that make this possible
um
you know i think that kind of went both
ways you know sort of like howard there
were some things right about what howard
was saying just like there's some things
right about what they say about him
but they're really through that lens
that he sees the world in and it kind of
came out and looked ugly as much as it
did you know as far as revealing
who they are you know what i mean like
they're reacting to that in a way as
well because howard's the one with power
you know what i mean he's the one with
power in the situation
so um
but yeah i see tons of people say that
they hate jimmy and kim regularly in the
comments of my video
that they're never going to be able to
redeem themselves and you didn't really
ever see that about walter you know
people
people either really liked him or they
didn't you know because they didn't
really get what the show was going for
yet you know what i mean like it took a
while to to dawn on some people
or they they you know or they know what
i mean
but there was never like
there was definitely a conversation
about when did he become heisenberg and
was he this way all along but that that
was sort of like in the in the in the
end you know what i mean
i definitely sympathize with the earlier
parts of or the earlier seasons but i
feel like part of season six is
that
him
unlikable because they were such likable
characters throughout the entirety of
the show but now they have to
almost devolve into the saul goodman
that we know from breaking bad so i do
think that the show's doing a great job
making them less likeable and they
definitely did that on purpose and i
mean i do kind of hate them now after
after this episode i mean not completely
i still like the characters i love the
actors but
i mean i don't know i think i i think
that they need to get what's coming for
them after all this
yeah i'm not there as far as i mean i i
think it made them more complicated but
i don't really know how it really it
changed too much like i can't even think
of what they did in this episode i mean
the consequences are bad and all of that
but i mean they they certainly didn't
intend for that to happen
yeah it's not like they planned howard's
death it definitely was just a crossfire
but after i mean i i kind of already
hated them just from you know seeing how
seeing how much they screwed over howard
with the whole mediation even before i
knew he was gonna die
uh so i don't know i know that the
creators definitely did mention how they
needed to make the characters less
likeable in this season to kind of
tie into breaking bad so that is
definitely something that they had
planned for for a little bit here
yeah and i i think it comes down to sort
of like the howard you know before we
had chuck versus jimmy like is you know
who do you who who's right who whose
side are you on and and it pretty much
breaks down to the person that you
relate to more
if you can relate more to chuck then you
think that he's right and that you know
he's
he wasn't as bad as everybody made him
out to be and if you relate more to
jimmy then you know then you know
whatever so i feel like that that that
has a lot to do with whether people
get really uh caught up with the whole
idea of howard you know i mean like
maybe they see themselves in that and
they feel like this injustice is a
little bit more
you know
it hits them a little bit more that way
holden thompson two dollars do you think
gene and jimmy are related somehow
that's pretty good
that's a pretty good one i read the
whole thing before i realized what he
was saying thank you for that
might be long lost twins
yeah jeffrey townsend
thank you for the 10 canadian it would
be satisfying to see a little into the
lives of skyler marie walt jr and holly
in a post-breaking bad bcs world
and whether the schwartz gave junior the
9 million
um
it would be satisfying to see a little
bit into their
oh yeah
i don't know that that's true
um i mean i see where you're coming from
i don't think for me that i that i want
to see that that was actually my least
favorite thing about the whole ending if
it has a flaw that that is the flaw that
walter got to give them the money um
well i don't know
they they they spent so long making him
the bad guy and then they they kind of
re redeemed him and and it just didn't
really seem necessary um even like when
it was happening it was
sort of like well why does he get to do
that you know i mean i was happy for
these fictional characters that they
wouldn't that they might not you know
have to deal with the consequences of
what their what he did what what their
you know husband and father did but
a lot of people did have to deal with
those consequences you know what i mean
and
he sort of
yeah like i said it's not it doesn't
ruin the whole thing for me but it's not
it's not my favorite part of the way
they decided to end the story it almost
feels like a checklist you know what i
mean like okay well
you know yeah he he did all this bad
stuff but he you know he but he dies at
the end and is in kind of at his own way
after he saves
jesse and then he also you know
since so since his family's sympathetic
we gotta give that part where he he
actually helps them out even though he
shouldn't really be able to
would you like to see that
i mean i mean i i would like to see the
outcome of it
i they it's they did set it up for the
possibility of that happening but we
never know if it actually does come to
fruition or not or if it even is
feasible because we know i mean i know
they have the whole excuse about you
know elliot and gretchen being the ones
to give it to them but
i mean what's walt's family does not
want that money and who knows if they're
actually going to end up sending it to
them so it's kind of uh walt died
thinking that everything was okay but
who knows if everything actually is okay
and if they can actually fulfill what he
wanted them to do so who knows for all
they know that maybe and i mean
they are they are scared to death of the
laser pointers but and they don't know
that they are just laser pointers so i
mean maybe maybe uh fear as motivation
is enough for them but but who knows
maybe maybe they don't ever give that
money to walt's family
yeah i never really thought that that as
a as an option i mean they're they're
the kind they're they're what you would
imagine are billionaires right i mean
they're the kind of people that it
doesn't make any difference to them and
they are human like they definitely
had compassion for the family and the
situation they were going through so
i always figured that they would make
that happen
okay fair enough but but i mean you know
it's it's it's but i got you know like
do you do you feel like they should they
should wrap it up like that's where
you're at or
you're okay with the mystery
i mean i'm kind of okay with the mystery
i don't really feel like it's something
that needs to be happened or needs to be
answered i am curious but i'm okay with
just leaving it as is
cool
all right
insane
asian i think 88
insane
asian
10 thank you
jesus christ
corral do we think there was an
intentional parallel between howard
falling and hitting his head
versus chuck falling and hitting his
head in the copy room
um i didn't think it was an intentional
like you know like that it made a
difference in in how things went down
but you could definitely draw that
you can you can make that comparison
though you know definitely
did you see that is that the first thing
you thought about chase whenever you saw
him hit his head was that chuck shot
honestly honestly yeah i mean
i
i def that definitely did come to mind
and i i do think it was somewhat
intentional i'm not sure if there's a
grandiose significance to it other than
just you know kind of reminding jimmy of
chuck during this howard moment but i
just just how hard he bashed his head
off of the off of the coffee table when
he was going down i i definitely do
think that was intentional at least to
some extent
fair enough i think that that you know
that some other people are you know
chiming in on there too that it
definitely
felt
intentional
you know what it's interesting when you
think about it because
that the the brutality of the way he
went down there is what caused jimmy to
do the right thing you know
and here we are in a situation where
there really isn't much wiggle room like
he can't there's not much he can do that
you could say is the right thing you
know
i mean the just a realization too little
too late possibly
that's what i mean it feels a lot more
like that right that it's just okay well
you realize this is horrible but there's
nothing you can do about it and i
thought there was
a nice parallel between you know what
they were trying to do to howard and
what they pulled off was exactly what
happened to them you
know they understand they understand
their mistake they understand who
who you know made everything go wrong
but they they're literally it's too late
they're now they're in it and
there's not much they can do
in you know to change their uh situation
yeah i mean maybe that could be why saul
becomes so jaded in breaking bad and and
also it does make me think back to the
uh the el camino missing scene of mike
and jesse where mike tells him that
making things right is the one thing you
sadly can't do
yep
and i think that we're getting to a
point where we're gonna have to wind
down um
i've got to
oh well while you have this photo of
irene on the screen i did want to
mention um what did you think about
howard kind of manipulating her and
putting her in that wheelchair to almost
pull a sympathy card because
i definitely feel like it this season
howard has kind of paralleled jimmy in
the earlier seasons in regard to
manipulating the elders um we saw howard
win them over and i think it was uh 605
and uh now just and i mean that was kind
of understandable but this whole thing
with putting her in a wheelchair just
seems a little bit over the top
yeah i thought it was a good i thought
it was a nice touch to
just remind you because like i said they
were going so hard to make you feel bad
for him you know they were doing all
this stuff like i thought there was also
kind of a fake out whenever
the kid drops the young lawyer drops the
the sodas you know
it almost felt like howard was gonna
berate him you know like how could you
do this like what are you thinking you
know because he's under all this stress
but he actually turns out to be nice
there
and then whenever he talks to to uh
irene like you said you know he he he
totally manipulates her and he acts like
she's not even there like she doesn't
know what's happening you know what i
mean so it's even a little bit dirtier
when you think about it
yeah i just think that's a side of
howard that he doesn't really show often
but it just does show that you know as
much as we care for him he isn't this
sort of perfect angel that maybe you
know people like me and others have
fully drank in the howard kool-aid you
know might think
yeah he's he's he's a complicated
character he's like a real person you
know he you can't put him on the good
guy or bad guy side there's there's way
too much that we know and we don't and
compared to some of the other characters
we didn't even know that much about him
a few episodes ago you know it turned
out
but yeah i think that i think that you
know he's he's he's a great complicated
character i love him or hate him you got
to feel for him and you have to
recognize the fact that
his flaws and his good points side by
side are what make him so compelling
ebeth barr thank you for the 9.99 thank
you for the analysis i just love that
bcs is a show that rewards paying
attention
even when the pace is slower makes it
worth it and we still have a half season
for more to pay off and i agree and i i
was i was really kind of frustrated
whenever i was doing the recap and
talking about
you know
everything that happened because there
were so many great little details and i
just couldn't actually get into all of
them and still kind of
get to the end of what was you know
really going on you know what i mean
like like i said earlier in this stream
you know it was like one thing after the
other it's like it's just like you were
getting hit by a payoff or a reference
or a character moment you know thinking
oh this might be the last time we see
them you know like irene
we might not see her again
we might not see hhm again you know the
how howard dying that might be the last
time that they ever have to go back to
that location that we've been going to
for six seasons so
yeah i love it too i mean it was they're
doing a really masterful job of
of making sure they hit all those things
i mean howard's brains were splashed on
the picture
that they had the post-it notes on
and
that we know shows up in saul's
uh house in the beginning
you know
yeah yeah i mean that's the thing with
this show it definitely is possible for
a lot of casual viewers just to sit back
and enjoy it but
you really get rewarded the more you pay
attention in regards to the props that
are on screen the way the cinematography
is shown the things that characters say
the things they don't say even in minor
points of dialogue where you think okay
i can kind of look at my phone you know
this isn't really important we get key
points of dialogue in regards to
howard's marriage or kim's past and this
show really rewards you the the more you
pay attention and that's one thing i
love
about breaking bad and better call saul
is the more you re-watch this show it's
like every time you re-watch it you come
out of it with a different perspective
or you learn something new and you grow
more appreciation for it in ways that
you weren't otherwise aware of
yeah and and one thing uh i think we'll
say 10 more minutes how does that sound
to you
yeah sure man sounds good
i mean unless something changes
massively here but um yeah i think i
think
uh you know there's there's a point
where it starts to get more difficult to
even pay attention and
that's probably the time whenever start
drifting off
yeah because i mean this is i i pulled
one of those uh
like i was telling you earlier i pulled
a lala whenever i i finished my other
video i took my nap and i woke up
exactly one minute before the alarm was
going to go off and i was like this is
uh this is
totally lollo
a total wallow
yeah i feel like one out of every 10
times you take a power nap it's actually
beneficial other times you just wake up
even more tired
yeah and i mean it was you know it was
necessary i had that was you know
basically my night you know what i mean
so it was oh geez
definitely had to have after putting
that putting yesterday together i had i
definitely had to get some downtime
before we did this but
um what you were talking about there
uh you know that we were talking about
the details and stuff one of the things
that is standing out to me at this point
is the misdirection
and you know this because you do the
trailer breakdowns too you know they've
been pretty they've been pretty uh
heavy-handed as far as like you know
making them
trying to
to misdirect us with those and then
there's been things in the episodes as
well which is is kind of interesting um
like the caffeine thing from last week
you know they definitely made a point to
to bring up the idea of caffeine and
then show howard um
drinking herbal tea
so that that's in your mind you know
what i mean
and so
i i think that that's that's kind of fun
you know i mean at this point in the
game that they're they're
they're really engaging with the way
that we're watching it you know what i
mean
and it feels like they're they're doing
a pretty good job of that if they're
like okay we know what they're gonna
think if we show them this or if we do
this
so let's play with that a little bit you
know
there's there's definitely always a lot
of misdirect and revolve in in you know
in regards to the trailers and the way
that they set things up like how i said
earlier where you thought that maybe the
pi was gonna get howard into trouble
with the cartel and then oh he wasn't
actually even working for howard he was
in on it the whole time but howard ended
up getting it in the long run so i don't
know just things and regardless of if
it's in the trailer or a misdirect from
the show i feel like they do it in a
good way like i don't feel like it's a
cheap tactic like i know some other
shows that i've broken down trailers for
that i've just seen trailers for in
general they kind of chop the trailers
you know together to be a little bit
cheap uh but i don't feel like this show
does it and also for the most part i
feel like this show does a good job with
the trailers of keeping you interested
and intrigued on what's going to happen
in future episodes but
excuse me sorry with but without
spoiling too much and honestly usually
what we see in the trailers usually ends
up happening in the first few scenes of
the episode so even if you do watch the
trailers and you go really in depth with
it you usually get all the answers
within the first few minutes and then
the rest of the episode is just kind of
you know spoiler free completely new
territory
yeah and i mentioned it earlier when we
were talking about the um
the timeline thing it doesn't feel like
any of it's really cheap to me i think
it's more playful you know like i said
that they they're they're kind of
anticipating how we're going to
interact with things and that that's a
lot of fun you know that makes that
makes it more rewarding to me and
it's funny because agent neptune here
thank you for the five dollars mentions
when cadillac and that's another one of
those things you know we saw that in the
trailer and we thought oh he's going to
be riding around in the cadillac the
whole time
and instead we saw that being impounded
from his house in the future instead
it's a good question i don't know when
it's going to come up
it feels a little bit disconnected from
where we're at because
i don't really see how i don't i mean
there doesn't seem to be a need for him
to upgrade at the moment
you know things are put kind of on pause
because of lalo but we'll have to wait
and see how they move past that
yeah i mean in regards to uh the
cadillac i believe in uh
season five near the end when they went
to the uh cartel safe house we actually
saw
what could have been saul's cadillac and
some uh some low-level grunts or
henchmen or whatever
they were cleaning blood off of it like
someone killed themselves and or someone
was shot in it so there is the popular
theory that saul gets the uh the
cadillac as sort of a reward from the
cartel i'm not sure if that was just an
easter egg or if that's ever gonna come
to fruition but definitely been waiting
for saul to get the cadillac ever since
then so who knows honestly
yep and adh whiskey thank you for the
eight dollars donald audio catches win
that lalo told hector he was going to
kill gus against his wishes
eladio orders twins to kill lalo
or dis for disobeying him boom
[Music]
yeah well the whole thing with uh lala
wanting to kill gus is that he needs
proof and enough reason to warrant gus's
death otherwise he knows the cartel
won't be okay with it so that's kind of
why lala's been on this wild goose chase
to kind of find some incriminating
evidence against gus so that he can take
him out because i think he does know
that if he just randomly takes out gus
without giving a solid reason why then
the cartel would be mad at him and not
just him but
the entirety of all the salamancas as
well
yeah and i mean you have to keep that in
mind that
you know a lot of times people overlook
it like these people have complete
agency but they all do answer to the
cartel
and eladio is on the top of that
on the top of that pyramid and you know
if you don't do what he wants you to do
then he can make you go away and it's
not really an issue and i i don't think
that that's like i see where adhd
whiskey is adhd whiskey's coming from
here
i don't think that's the direction it's
going but yeah it's something to think
about i guess
i i that
i kind of feel like the twins i don't
know
that seems like it would be a little
contrived if if they just had to make up
something to you know have the twins
killing lalo because they're they're
kind of devoid of feeling those two
characters you know i mean so like
they wouldn't be the best vehicle for
that in my mind but we'll have to wait
and see
let's see what else we got i see that
uh i see a uh
severance uh
a severance uh
refer reference here
which uh
i thought that's what that was i thought
that's what that was i just had a little
bit of
disassociation here uh
you just
yeah you just watched severance for the
first time this week
oh yeah yeah i'm a i'm a i'm a big
severance fan now i i am anxiously
awaiting season two might have to
discuss it in a video at some point but
yeah yeah definitely on the severance
fan boat here i i jumped on the
bandwagon and i'm really glad i did
yeah
trying not to try not to spoil anything
in case you know the people watching
haven't seen it but there's only only
one season nine episodes i definitely
recommend checking it out if you haven't
absolutely big mac 076
thank you for the 4.99 thoughts on the
black and white scene directly after the
credits jimmy alludes to a happy ending
yeah we talked about this yesterday in
chat uh or you know
in messages um
that was my takeaway was that it's it's
it's purposely it's like it's vague on
purpose so that you don't know if it's
in the gene timeline or if this is
something that happens between
now and whenever breaking bad starts
have you evolved on that at all or are
you in the same boat
i am still unsure of if it is a gene
scene or if it is just a misdirect and
this is after you know the aftermath of
howard obviously it shows kim's
apartment and there's no blood anywhere
there isn't howard's body so seems like
there's at least a little bit of a time
skip uh seeing the black and white you
know the show has trained us to think
that it is a gene scene uh but how far
in the future is this is this you know
you know gene season six or what is the
deal with that and and also just the
fact that jimmy's voice sounds so young
when he's saying it um i almost wonder
if it's a little bit of uh the trailer
trickery that we were just talking about
a moment ago where maybe this could be
jimmy talking during the better call
salt timeline but
it could be actually showing a gene
scene and i i'm just really curious like
does kim still live in that apartment
all the way through breaking bad into
the gene scene because that seems a
little bit unrealistic but i i guess it
is possible but
all the furniture is exactly the same
too so yeah i just i i'm still
still really flip-floppy with that one
yeah i think it i think it's it's a shot
of the of the
i think it's a shot of the apartment in
the current timeline and then they added
black and white to make you think about
the you know the future
but then
the the the actual thing that he says
after all of that a happy ending that
seems like it would make a lot more
sense in the gene timeline like there
really isn't a happy ending coming after
howard getting shot you know what i mean
yeah yeah exactly what would the happy
ending be like her getting away or them
not getting in trouble i mean we know
that there's going to be big changes
before we get to where gene's at so
yeah i think that you're right it it
does sound like it doesn't sound like
gene necessarily but i feel like it's
more likely that that's something that
he'll say in the gene timeline
and then we we're seeing there you know
we're seeing that apartment because
that makes us think of the current
timeline and it makes it all seem so
much more mysterious
christian
chuck cohn thank you for the 4.99
although i predicted howard dying this
season i was still shocked and saddened
by it thanks for the content i'm a big
fan of the show love for hh
howard hamlin definitely sad to think
that hhm all three of those guys don't
exist anymore
yeah yeah i do i i always wanted some
sort of uh concrete info about howard's
dad because i don't really think we got
much about it um in the therapy session
i think howard says that he had a dream
that he was helping his dad go on an
international flight and he was trying
to help him with the ticket but i think
really that's in aside from uh back in
season two i think him saying how uh he
wanted to you know start his own
practice but his dad wanted him to add
another h to the logo i think those are
the only two moments we've ever heard
about howard's dad so it is implied that
you know he's you know dead but i i'm
still unsure when and how
um i i do think that he's dead just
because that's probably why howard has
such a connection with chuck because uh
he was his dad's partner and also so
sort of his only fog father figure that
was left um
but yeah i would have liked some more
concrete info on uh uh hamlin senior
yeah i mean i i don't think there's any
question that he's dead but you know
we don't know
i mean we know that he had an influence
on howard's life he's the reason that he
came into that you know he became the
second h on the sign
but it doesn't look like we're going to
learn many more you know much more about
that so thanks for that christian uh
kakuzato thank you for the two pounds or
the two euros awesome content love you
guys
thanks for that it's always good to hear
yeah and we are
we are at the end of the road
so
why don't you
why don't you um
plug your channel and talk about the you
know
what you do over there
and then we'll uh sign off here
yep for sure so um over on my channel i
do a lot of uh breakdowns on uh certain
topics on uh on certain scenes i usually
like to take a particular scene and go
really in depth with it
during the mid-season break i'm going to
go back to doing my tier lists where i
rake each episode of a season on a tier
list and just give almost a general
recap for that particular season uh
heading in into uh
uh the the final part of season six and
then once season six is over still got a
lot of uh better call saul and breaking
bad content planned gonna go back and do
a bunch of character retrospectives and
and all of that so uh
yeah yeah definitely come check me out
vivid kiwi got a bunch of uh breaking
bad uh universe content uh planned for
for the next while but um also looking
to branch out to other shows such as
such as severance i mean i'm always
looking for a good show to cover so not
only breaking bad and better cost all
but that's that's definitely uh my main
uh priority right now
all right yeah thanks for coming out um
we'll we'll be having you again uh we're
gonna be
talking about doing some of these
streams during the break and uh we'll
see how that goes there was one question
here before we go how did the pictures
of the judge how did they get switched i
i thought that the uh
pi probably did that when he was in
there since he's a con man
in the first place what did you think
chase
yeah i think that the pi just switched
the photos while howard was getting
ready for the meeting essentially
all right so thanks everyone for coming
out thank you for all of the super chats
and uh thanks everyone for sticking
around if you did
we really appreciate that it's a lot of
fun to talk about all this stuff and get
to have a couple of my friends come by
and uh you know just get into things a
little bit deeper because whenever you
do recaps you got to kind of keep
everything short and to the point
and
this stuff is so rich that it's really
fun to have a deeper conversation about
it so thanks to everyone
guests and viewers alike we'll be doing
it next time that for sure we'll be out
back again whenever episode 8 comes out
but keep an eye out because i'll have
new videos this week about the you know
going into some other things that happen
in the finale and there will definitely
be more live streams to come so
let's leave it there thanks for coming